Work. OBS. Sometimes it just ends after I started. I love it when it does that. Okay, I didn't do it though.
Yippee!
Maybe you mute myself so I don't hear myself.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Because you are so fucking small.
You are on us. Okay, if we're legit with how tall you are and how tall I am.
So I am like this. My legs are so fucking long, bro. And then there's you. You'd be like down here.
You'd be like that.
Wasn't you? Yeah, you a shawty.
Oh, you're so small. I can just move you around. Yeah, she's like my little doll. Oh wow, she's like my little...
Oh, you're muted? Oh, you are muted.
You attached me. You attached me to you.
Get me off!
Oh, you're so cute. It's like I'm holding onto you like a little puppet.
Set me free. Let me go.
My cute little sister and me.
Okay, I'll make you bigger.
Oh my god.
Thank you. Perfect.
A happy family. I can't even see my chat. That's why I didn't know you were muted. Hold on.
Oh my god. So how's everybody doing?
Hope everyone's doing well. Yeah, I'm getting ads on my own video.
Wait, really? Yeah.
I should have just not monetized it. She's a little brats. The immuppet. Oh my god, Emmy Muppet.
No, oh my god, people are gonna fuck the immuppet.
Toma's already working on a Muppet for you.
Oh, now I gotta use it.
She just was doing it for fun for our designs, but she's like, yeah, I just want to make one based off of Muppets.
She's making you, she's basing you off of the rat.
And I'm like, she'll love that.
Um, but yeah, me and...
G-U-E-R-I-L-L-A.
Did I add an extra L? Okay, no, I didn't.
So you probably saw the silliness that took place. It looks like we're about to do an apology video.
We're sorry for getting Strawny's channel a-straked.
We're sorry for cooking you by having sex with each other.
In discord.
We will never do such a thing again.
Oh, really?
Um, no, but we were just hanging out after our collab earlier and me and Emmy had been cooking up something for you guys.
And so then we wanted to make a joke.
Then I was going through my scripts because I realized I could record scripts at the same time as being in a discord call.
So I'm like, ah, maybe Emmy can give me some pointers or whatever.
Am I moaning? Well, you can tell me.
And I'm reading the scripts and I'm like, wait, what the fuck is off the entirety of October?
Like, what is this? I can't.
And so I'm just posting screenshots and glimpses of the script.
And so I sent it to Emmy.
Um, and I don't know what we're going to do with it.
You want to act it out together?
I think that'd be cool if we just pick the worst one, you think?
Okay, okay.
Because I know for a fact that Strani's not going to have me do the scripts now.
You actually have the names of your scriptwriters. I never have names online.
The last one I don't have names on the scriptwriter and if I figured out who it was, I would fight them.
Because my scripts literally before October are fine.
Okay, okay.
Most of them are not that bad.
In October?
Yeah, I think it's just that one.
That one? I'm trying to find it. I don't know what that could just do with it.
I'm reading the other ones and they're not that bad. It's just that one.
Was that number two?
Um, it's number one.
Oh no, you didn't look at number two then.
What's wrong with number two?
Uh, face-mashing and slurping in a better mood, good snogging.
I'll make you forget all about her.
Here on Clash Rock, remember these?
The most mouth-watering tits you've ever put in your mouth. Play with those.
What the fuck are you reading?
I'm reading! I'm reading the second one.
I think it's like a third paragraph down.
Tummy Gurgle. Oh, look who's hungry now.
Sorry funnel cake is gone and the truck usually leaves by now.
I'm only teasing. I know this is a bit backwards, but how about there?
That's not that bad.
It's not, it's really...
Here, let's start, let's start around the...
She glurps his giggle stick against her face so much.
Where is, I can't add up to it.
Hold on, let me, let me control find giggle stick.
It's up medium.
I have like 101 things that contain giggle in my entire master's group.
Is the giggle stick two words? Okay, it is. I found it.
Okay, do you want to, do you want, I'll do the voice acting part and then you can read the direction?
Sure, sure, sure.
Okay, okay. So I'm going to start at enough.
Enough.
So if you go a couple sentences up, it's at the beginning of the paragraph.
Enough. She forces herself up.
Oh, I found it, I found it.
Okay, ready?
Take a sip of the water.
You guys are getting glorps on you.
Okay, you guys are getting insider information.
Although I know for a fact the script is not going to be used, but...
Enough.
She forces herself up and splurts his gock from her pummeled vagine.
You didn't have that bad a day to where I'm just going to let you forget your manners. Sit.
The toilet squeaks in resistance to both of their weight.
You're way too cocky for a man risking his entire livelihood in a public restroom.
And you forget that this rabbit...
She glorps his giggle stick against her fasal nut.
Is mine.
She begins sliding down and riding.
Aha, now who look who's whimpering like a bitch?
That's right, bitch.
Ha.
Domineering Humpery.
You ain't nothing but a bitch to me.
And y'all know, bitches ain't shit to me.
Fucking take it.
Ha.
If I were caught in make national headlines,
a bitch like you would probably be a single HR email.
Look at that pathetic fucking face.
He comes.
Huh? You came?
So...
Plop.
What?
Plopping intensifies.
I still need mine, bitch.
You selfish motherfucker.
You think you're better than me?
You think you're hot shit?
You think now that you've got a bit of cash?
You can have any girl you want.
Look at you.
You can't even have a girl show up to date you.
And you think you can come before me?
Ha ha.
I bet.
Door opens.
Get the fuck out.
Do the slams, cops!
Ha.
You're nothing.
Nothing.
You're fuck.
Fuck.
She whimpers into a shuttering orgasm.
Ha.
Oh.
You came again?
Ha.
Oh.
Wind down.
Like, wait.
Did he leave?
Like the door shut.
I don't...
No, someone walked in while they were doing it.
And then left.
That's what it was.
I'm dead.
Okay.
Ha.
That was amazing.
She takes some toilet paper to wipe the mess.
Here.
Let me clean you off.
Slurp.
Pop.
Ah.
You all right?
She begins dressing herself.
I kind of mashed you down into the toilet there.
Here.
Give me your hand.
She helps him up.
Up you go.
Oh.
Careful.
That's what it says.
Can't feel your legs.
Come on.
Lean on me.
Door opens.
Uh, or excuse us.
Time skip.
Okay.
Slowly.
Slowly on the bench.
They sit.
Oh.
I'll be right back.
She leaves.
Returns a bit later.
Here.
Some water.
Hold.
So nice.
I know.
It's looking nice.
Huh?
Oh, I just have sensitive teeth.
So, oh yeah.
They both drink?
How about the same cup?
I mean, they just, they just fucked in the bathroom.
So whatever.
Listen, I, uh, I'm sorry for what I said back there.
I know.
I know you're already having a shitty day and, uh, really?
Huh?
So you like that kind of talk, huh?
I guess with my line of work, I can pick up the kind of person who likes being talked
down to.
Tell me, Gurgle.
Oh, look who's hungry now.
Sorry.
Funnel cake is gone.
The truck usually leaves by now.
I'm only teasing.
I know this is a bit backwards, but how about dinner?
My treat.
Can you stand?
No rush.
All right.
Come on.
I know a place.
It's not far.
Wow.
How romantic.
Oh, look at that.
The bathroom and then went to, to a park bench.
I don't know.
No, I'm not.
We're not even reading fanfics, guys.
This is a script.
We're reading Shibi's scripts.
This is my, that was a script that was handed to me.
And thank you for that.
Do you want to read the first one?
Yeah, we can do it.
Oh, I think, I think the first one's a little bit.
This has to be an audio.
Come on.
You guys want that to be an audio?
All right.
That's the first one.
Oh, this one's ridiculous.
Is it all the pants and part?
Yeah.
My cat's trying to hop up on my lap.
Not now, Fia.
We're busy.
Okay.
We're fucking busy, Fia.
You can start.
Okay.
Beeping key card lock.
Unlock door.
Heels approaching.
Long night.
I startled you, didn't I?
I would have knocked, but I own the place.
I'm sorry.
She doesn't burp.
Your hotel room.
No, you're right.
This is a misunderstanding.
Just not the one you think it is.
Here.
Sit.
She pats the bed.
You're the one who is with that rowdy crowd at the bar, right?
The one's cheering like a Super Bowl riot.
She clicks her tongue shamingly.
No social awareness whatsoever.
Look at you.
Apologizing.
You're not in trouble.
Not yet, anyway.
Here.
Compliments of the hotel.
She pops a bottle, pours two drinks.
Actually, I would have celebrated with you all then and there if I wasn't paraded around
by my usual ass kissers and yes men.
So, what are we celebrating?
A promotion?
Oh, cheers to that.
She swirls her icing soups.
This is not bad.
Yeah, this one's not that bad, actually.
I don't know if you can hear the...
You probably can't hear the, um, the donos.
But someone said, thank you for the $2 tip.
Damn, I need a cold shower to calm my giggle stick after that slurping scenario.
Crick the fuck up.
Calm your giggle stick.
Oh, you can't hear them?
That's fine.
This was just lily a girl.
Guys, you don't have to donate for this.
Um, okay.
Let me see where was it.
Oh, you sounded...
What?
Go ahead, sorry, go ahead, go ahead, go ahead.
Hmm, you all sounded like you were having so much fun.
So, why did you leave early?
Tired?
Tired of what?
Huh, you know, I always like that phrase,
drain social battery.
It's a way more polite and succinct than fed up with everyone's bullshit.
Straight to the point, you know.
She takes one more sip and sets her drink down.
Ooh, which is how I like it.
Hmm, how I like everything, really.
Which brings me to you.
Even as the obvious quiet one of your group of friends,
you made it so hard not to notice you in that zoo of a booth.
A cutie.
She steps forward.
Like.
You.
She kisses the viewer.
Making out.
What's this here?
She rubs his erect stick through his pants.
That doesn't feel like the stick of a man who's tired.
In fact, it feels more of a stick that needs to be drained.
So how about it?
Shall we get to the point?
Good boy.
She nibbles at his neck kissing while she unbuckles his pants.
Disrose.
Here, let me slide these off.
Now, on the bed.
Good boy.
She crawls into the bed kissing and rubbing at his hips.
What is rubbing at his hips mean?
And now these.
Rubbing those hip bones.
She slides his tiny lighties off.
His tiny lighties off.
I didn't catch that one when I read it before.
It's always the quiet ones with the biggest sticks.
Why is that?
Rubbing a man with absolutely nothing to compensate for.
Glock suckering.
Feel nice.
Of course it does.
Slippery slobbering until she stops mid popsicle slurp.
Hey, do not touch the ears.
Good boy.
She continues into throating.
I think now that we should really get the celebration started.
What do you say, big shot?
That's what I like to hear.
Light teasing.
She slinks out of her ponzu.
Bring that dick here, boy.
She starts to grind on the tip before lightly slapping him.
Ah, ah, ah, don't get greedy now.
What's wrong?
Don't like my cat kissing the top of your stick?
Aw, but you're celebrating.
There's no need to rush this, baby.
We can party all night if you're able.
Just allow me to savor this a bit slowly.
Slowly on the tip.
She laughs as she swirls her hips just the bellend half inside.
And that's what it says.
It says bellend, everyone.
My big, heavy hips need to savor the shape of the tip.
Aw.
She slides her kitty down the top of his popsicle.
Glides so smoothly against the top of your popsicle.
Look at you.
We're supposed to be celebrating, weren't we?
I shouldn't be having all the fun, but I'm not fully sure you want this.
Say, if you had to choose between your new promotion and losing that position in exchange
for sliding the full length of your cat.
I mean, your dog all the way to the base inside of my tight, gripping cat.
What would you say right now?
Hmm?
Oh, I can't hear you.
Please?
Please, what?
That's please, madam.
Louder, boy.
Ah, good boy.
Now we can celebrate.
Segs, slow and heavy.
And it said with two G's.
With two G's, it says.
Hmm, almost.
She be laughs, releasing desperate exiles as she restrains herself to slowly descend down.
The popsicle in capital letters.
The Triton.
Yeah, the Triton's filling me so good.
Here, put your hands here.
Now, little man.
A nasty laughter.
You're going to want to hold on.
Heavy slapping, no pants dance, followed by animal grunting.
Yeah, all the way in.
Wetness increases.
Making your way up in the world.
Still yet, ungh, fucking beneath me.
No matter how hard you work, you'll always be nothing but a popsicle to do.
You want that, don't you?
That's yes, mistress.
Segs pauses.
Wait, wait, wait.
I need this bra off.
She releases her fat tiddage free from the burdens of a bra as she catches her breath.
Now.
Oh fuck, sex medium pace.
Have you ever seen a more perfect pair of fucking tits?
Oh, don't even answer that because you haven't.
And now, I want them in your mouth.
Sex reasons.
Ah, that's it.
Ah, that's...
Monkey noises.
Wait, this does monkey noises?
It says monkey noises.
Go on, make the monkey noises.
Ah, another one.
Ah, fit bath for those fat fuckers in your mouth.
Yes, yes.
Sex fast paced.
More, I want more.
Her pace becomes rapid and animalistic.
You small time bitch.
Fuck me, you're fucking nobody.
Are you coming?
Coming?
Fuck.
He fills sheebie to the brim with a nasty load of pent-up gunk.
Wind down, catching her breath.
Nothing like a little fireworks to cap off a party.
She slips from her drink.
Oh, goodness.
Look at all that flowing out.
I can tell you're a workaholic with no time to let loose.
Just look how much you let loose in me.
She laughs and then kisses him.
Look at that.
Such a content little smile.
Not that forced uncomfortable smile around your friends from the bar,
but a real one.
It's beautiful.
Oh, me.
You're too sweet.
I don't want anyone folk in my life,
but you, I can tell you're different.
Awkward pause.
Oh, um, that's stuff about you being a nobody.
I, um, I was just dirty talk.
I didn't mean that.
Any of it.
Everything good.
That's um, that's good.
Even more awkward pause.
Oh, um, I forgot that I had more work to do tonight.
She begins putting her clothes back on.
Oh, um, uh, keep the bottle top shelf stuff.
Or so they tell me.
I just told the bartender to give me something impressive and stiff.
Sounds like you.
Laughter trails off.
So, um, see ya.
Door closes.
Why was the ending so fucking unsexy?
Oh, come on.
That was it.
That was the first group.
The deku accent.
I literally, I have tears running down my face.
I know me too.
Oh, ooh, ooh.
Oh, tidy whitey.
Tidy whitey.
Oh, my God.
I just had to share this with you guys.
I know, I just tried to do a loser at the end.
Thank you for this super LP, 4145.
If this becomes an audio, I will seriously consider
something to my Patreon.
Oh my God.
No, guys, there's literally a full month of October
like this, the fucking monkey noises.
I'm like, do they hate me?
Why did they even write monkey noises?
Oh my God.
Whoever wrote those scripts cooked with gas.
Thank you, feel their love for this super.
All right.
Aside from the mildly racist undertones,
this is pretty funny.
Oh my God, I didn't even think about that.
I didn't notice.
Oh, you see, the sweet precious child.
I love you so much, Emmy.
When you said monkey, I just thought it related
to like animalistic, you know?
Yeah, the animalistic monkey noises.
Yeah, but he did write you a little stupidly.
Yeah.
No, so if you guys are new coming in,
I was in call with Emmy and we were working
on an audio together for something else
that she will probably finish up at some point.
And I can't wait for you guys to hear that.
We're very excited.
But I was like, oh, since I figured out
I can record during a call,
let me look at my stuff right now
and we can just like hang out and I can record
and you can like make fun of me, whatever.
So I'm looking at my October scripts.
I haven't recorded September yet.
I was looking at October because I was like,
oh yeah, what are my scripts again?
I didn't read it that far ahead.
And I'm just like, I'm like, what is this?
And I'm like sending screenshots in our discord
with the other girls.
And I'm like, Strani, Strani, please.
What is it?
What is this?
And I'm like, what are these?
What are these?
Oh, I'm like, she definitely, I'm like,
Strani probably had faith in the script writer
or that somebody was trolling
and just fucking just did something.
Or I don't know.
Maybe someone got hold of the link for my scripts.
I don't know.
So who knows?
I think it's genuinely the script writer.
I want to just note,
because my script writers usually write off
what they've written and this person did it.
And I feel like they did that on purpose.
They were ashamed, they were ashamed.
It's great though.
So that was, that's the first script for,
it's called Entanglements.
It's a Shelby or Shibi.
And it's supposed to be, that was,
it's a four for the entire month.
It's just a continuation.
It's a story.
You know what I think we should do, Amy?
I think we should do the other scripts.
You want to spoil them?
At a later time.
I'll ask Strani if we could do,
I think she'll be fine if we did this one.
But I think if we did that as like a little Mimi joke,
or if I record them seriously with you narrating the activity,
I think that would be absolutely peak.
It would.
Yeah.
And we can just like upload both to our,
both of our Patreons.
That would be funny.
I don't think any of the other girls had stuff like this.
I think it was just me.
Yeah, I don't have anything like that,
but I haven't like,
they haven't written up to October for me.
Yeah.
So that's why.
So I don't know if like the script writers,
but it's good because it's good that I fucking noticed it
because I would hate for the girls to get other stuff.
And like, like I see who I know,
Strani was saying who's ESL might not like,
quite understands like, okay,
I guess I just read this then.
And think that it's like sounds okay when it doesn't.
Honestly though, I think I see would have noticed
and been like, what is this?
Yeah.
I don't think I see would just like read out like,
yeah.
Lucky noises.
Oh, this is, this would be funny for April Fool's as well.
Just do like a meme-y, like really meme-y,
lewd audios for, oh my God.
I'm asking Strani about that.
I think that's a good idea.
Yeah.
It's Tracy and Daddy ESL.
I don't think, yeah.
Yeah, you're right, you're right.
Kickles.
Oh my God.
But I hope we didn't stress Strani out too much.
I mean, she was gonna find out sooner or later.
It'd be funny if I like center the audio.
I should, I imagine if I didn't say anything
and I just recorded it, it just said it to her.
I don't think she listens to our audio,
so I think it would have passed.
I think you're the only one who got scripts like this
because you're the only one to view a letter
that can turn a sex script into a joke
with my impersonations.
It's beat comedy.
Thank you for this, I like that.
That's good.
Give that a little heart.
It's for myself.
That's so great.
I guess Strani was more,
way more stressed by her card game.
Yeah, I saw she was, she was sweating a little bit.
Oh my God.
But thanks for stopping by Emmy.
I just asked,
because I know Emmy has some stuff to get done.
So thank you for spending time with me real briefly.
Thanks for having me.
I love you, Emmy.
I love you too.
Have fun, what are you doing next?
I don't know, I'm probably just gonna yap.
Okay, have fun yapping.
Yeah, I'm something, I don't know.
I'll see you later.
Bye, Harold.
And the pin pals.
We got some pin pals in the chat.
Pin pals, goodbye, goodbye.
See you later.
Bye, bye, bye.
Wait, I forget that I have to like, quit the collab.
She's like, stop it.
She's like, doing stuff.
All right, I'm sorry, little sister gone.
Okay.
I'm like so far behind in my own bond.
I'm like, what the fuck?
Oh, I'm not leaving it.
I'll probably like stay on for a little bit,
but like, yeah, I just had to share that with you guys.
I love Emmy so much.
We've been in call.
We were in call together for a little bit,
and then Mercy had some stuff to do too.
Cause it was literally like me, I see Mercy and Emmy
and Strani for a little bit, just hanging out.
And Strani had a stream.
I see how to go to bed to pour a little polar bear.
And Azura was streaming,
and then Mercy had to go take care of some stuff.
So, but that was, it was,
so yeah, me and, me and Emmy were just like chatting.
And I'm just like, you know,
cause she has a lot more experience with me
than me with like audios and stuff.
So I was just like grabbing pointers from her.
And she's like, you're doing really good.
I'm like, yeah.
And then I'm like, let me look at my audios.
And let me look at my script.
And I was like, wait a second, something's not right.
Something's not right.
This is the most feeler.
I was really funny.
It was really funny.
It was really fun.
Yeah, so the whole month of October is like that.
November and December are still on the writing stage.
I haven't started recording September yet,
but I was gonna record September
after the, I got off Call of Emmy,
but then I got distracted with this.
But yeah, cause I think October was supposed to be the month
where I was like the Dommie month,
but like, I'll be honest with you.
There's just, you can just like,
some of my first scripts were written by like Strani.
And you could tell like a woman wrote them
versus like a man writing this,
although this is definitely very meme-y.
So I don't know if like they were taking it serious.
I don't know.
But then I have like one of our other script writers,
Etwa, and they have good scripts too.
So I'm like, they wrote very similarly to Strani.
So I'm like, okay, maybe, I don't know.
Maybe they just like never written before.
I don't know what happened.
I also didn't tweet.
I'm sorry.
I didn't like tweet to say I was live or anything.
I was just like, I'm here.
So I apologize.
Cause I was just like, okay, we need to tell the people this
and give them an explanation as to what we were doing in Call.
Although we immediately prepared ourselves
and we heard Strani's like, we're gonna hop and call.
And we were like, okay, start moaning.
Start doing stuff.
But I hope that gets clipped cause it would be so funny.
Um, yeah.
It was literally, but it's not even chat, GPT,
chat, GPT would not write something like that.
Chat, GPT would never write something like that.
I don't think.
But it was, yeah, it was so bad.
It was great.
I can imagine the script writer must have felt bad
about writing a lot of script
and so I had some meme humor in the parentheses
since narration isn't meant to be read out loud.
Yes, but even like, even with the dialogue
in the later scripts, it's not good.
And that was just the first script.
It gets progressively worse.
And we have more than one script writer.
So it's not like one person is writing 30 scripts a month.
It's like there's multiple people writing us scripts.
And then Strani will also like chime in
every once in a while as well.
As a lead translator myself,
these scripts were not something I never considered
except it will work for me.
Kind of, exactly.
It's like when I, one, they're doing a lot of like direction
and then like when I, I don't know,
maybe it's because like one of our other script writers
and Strani just writes differently when they give me scripts,
but they do a lot of like direction and what's going on.
They're doing a lot of saying and not,
or they're doing a lot of showing and not saying,
which is not what you do for an actual script.
At some point you should hold script writing competitions
and pick the best four for each month.
Oh, that'd be pretty cool.
For like maybe like a special month, we do that.
That'd be really nice.
That's a good idea.
Bring out with Strani.
She be a bridge.
That's literally, this is the month of October,
she be a bridge.
Big shout out to Smoothie for a good evening.
Big shout out to Smoothie for their viewer debut.
Oh, a hundred percent, yes.
Thank you so much to Smoothie
for doing a debut compilation of us.
I was like, holy crap, this is awesome.
It was so good.
I was laughing.
I'm like, I was so embarrassed.
The first opening line for the video
is welcome to be sucky fucky.
Well, where did you fucky?
You're sucking whatever the fuck I said.
I was like, oh my God.
Yeah, mommy's scripts are very, very good.
And I've also learned a lot
since I've started doing scripts,
like what you guys like, what you guys don't like
and like how you want me to read things.
I've also fixed my 3DO.
So it's, yeah, please watch Smoothie's video.
It was really, really funny
how he edited us all together.
But yeah, so, and I'm probably gonna hold
some sort of like script writing stream when I come back
because, and I've mentioned doing this before,
before I read the script, but I'm like, okay,
if this is the script that gets submitted,
I know I can write better than this.
Because like for example,
it's like everything's like, when like Shrani writes,
it's like everything's guided and like by word of mouth
and it's very, it's very like seductive and alluring.
And it's like, she's through the dialogue,
she's telling you what's happening.
But this person was mostly just writing direction
and it was very odd.
I'm like, we're not acting it out,
but I'm so sorry to the script writer if you're watching,
but that was very silly.
There were some very, very good things in there.
Hi, hi, hi.
But yeah, I wanted to like hop on and show you guys that,
but I can't wait for you guys to listen to the audio
that me and Amy just did together.
It was really nice.
You guys don't like it.
But yeah, it's inspired by a certain someone
who did a similar script in the past
that a lot of people enjoyed.
And so we wanted to do one ourselves.
Script writer, you cooked, but it was the wrong menu.
Honestly, facts, like the script is awesome,
but it's awesomely bad.
But it's like, you know, like it's like,
I'm trying to say this as nice as way possible.
Yeah, a certain someone.
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Hello, hello.
Where is the audio gonna be uploaded?
I think she's uploading it to Twitter.
I think part one, there's two parts,
part one, I think will be on mine
and I think part two will be on mine,
either one, we each have a part.
Amy's a good script writer.
She's also a very good actress
because we were in call together, working out the script.
And so I had to sit there and listen to her, do her lines,
and I'm trying so hard not to laugh.
Yeah, it'll be a Twitter audio, I'm pretty sure.
Just so everybody can see it.
Yeah, it's a short thing.
It's not like 10 minutes long.
It's literally like two minutes, if not shorter than that.
Her audio with IC was base.
I heard it was, I heard it was really good.
You're gonna piss myself laughing.
I lost it, yeah.
Dude, I was literally losing it in the call with Emmy.
I'm like, Emmy, please look at this.
Please tell me I'm not going crazy.
And then I posted it and I was like, manager,
is this your fault?
And they were just like, why am I catching strays?
No.
And I'm like, I'm telling Strani.
And I'm like, Strani, please, please.
That's when I hopped around like Emmy, let's hop in the call.
And she's like, oh my God, but we were cackling so hard.
But now I know what you guys get for Emmy's audios.
She gave me a little taste and I'm like, okay.
All right, all right.
Oh my gosh, I can see.
Like, damn, my little sister's so talented.
And I'm like, how do I sound like that?
Like teach me your ways.
She does spoil you.
I was like, damn.
I was gripping my mouse, listening to her like, excuse me.
I want to be just like Emmy.
But it was, yeah, it was really fun to record.
And then now that I know that we both know
that we can record stuff in calls with each other,
we definitely want to get the other girls
to record stuff with us in calls
because it would just be so funny.
And then we can also give each other like tips and stuff.
And then like, yeah, I think it would just be great.
Nilsis, Emmy, Big Sis, Gibi, exactly.
But yeah, I'm sure, like the pin pals
are definitely gonna like it.
Harem is definitely gonna like it.
But yeah, the wholesome bonding, 100%.
Yeah, I like, I love spending time every time.
One of the girls left the call
when we were like all like kind of trickling off
to do our stuff that we had to get done,
whether it be like audios, scripts or whatever.
Smacked my hand on the table.
I'm like, like I see left.
I was like, I love that bear.
And Mercy left.
I'm like, I love that yandere.
Amy left.
I didn't say anything, but you guys know that I love her.
I love that little pumpkin girl,
that little hex maniac.
Anyone idea what's gonna drop?
Oh, I don't know.
Emmy has a lot of projects going on right now.
She's cooking up a bunch of stuff for you pin pals.
So just wait, don't worry.
But we both recorded it in like 10 minutes.
So it's really, she has to edit and stuff.
I asked her if she needed help.
She says, she's like, oh, I'm just gonna edit.
I'm like, okay.
I kind of want to teach her to teach me how to edit
and as well as Strani to teach me how to edit that stuff.
Cause usually I just like send it off to the audio editor
and then like insert all the like sound effects
and all that stuff.
It would be cool to like learn how to do that.
But yeah, it was, it was really fun and it was funny.
Like I would be using like my mommy voice.
I'd be like, come on little girl and be like, hey.
And she was like, it was really funny.
And then when she was making like her portion
that I'm not going to spoil.
I was like screaming internally.
So I hope you guys like it.
But yeah.
I hope you guys liked also the title of my stream,
something simple, something giggle stick.
I need to sneeze.
Thank you.
But yeah, it's really small and short,
but I think you guys will like it.
So short, sweet to the point.
Thank you, thank you.
But yeah, it means converting she be into someone.
I think honestly, I think, yeah.
I think I'm definitely being, I'm getting Emmy Pilled.
Can my allergies have been acting up like for the past few days?
I've been like sniffing a whole bunch.
But yeah, I hope you guys shibbling.
Don't get me started on the cotton bum family.
I literally just did that off the rip, by the way.
I don't even, I was possessed by some incestuous devil
to just do all that random ass lore.
I'm so sorry for some of you.
I thought it was funny as hell.
Based on yesterday's stream,
I think Emmy fully converted you already 100%.
Bro, imagine she being Emmy playing Kauffman,
Andy and Lillie.
That would be so funny.
If we did a collab stream playing Kauffman,
Andy and Lillie.
And like I voiced Andy and she voices Ashley.
I think that would be really, really funny
before building that day was wild it was.
But I just wanted to like do something kind of silly
and kind of like ridiculous.
Well, you guys literally watched me farm for four hours.
Honestly, I don't even remember farming.
I don't even, I generally don't even remember
what I was doing.
I just like shot a bird for four hours.
I got four million runes.
And yeah, and I just wanted you guys to laugh a bunch.
Don't lie, you've been playing this lore
since before your debut.
No, I usually actually was like never really
into that sort of stuff.
But like I get the allure.
Ha ha, ha ha, the V allure.
So I'm like, you know what?
Let me do a little treat for like the harem
cause usually you don't get that from me.
Let me do that.
And you guys know like I love being cute and funny sometimes.
Like it kind of like, I can like,
I feel like I show a different side of myself
when I get to be like shebethany and be cute and funny.
And then when I'm sheby, I can be like, you know,
my more like mommy adult self.
Oh, and you know, it's very, it's always fun.
I like, cause I, you guys know,
I used to be cute and funny on the daily.
So I'm at my PL.
So it's, I kind of miss that sometimes.
But I also just love being a big powerful woman
with drill hair.
Yeah.
I think you're always cute and funny.
Oh, thank you, so sweet.
But yeah, I think I'm, I mean, I see they've got me.
I'm like, oh man, I miss like that sort of stuff.
I miss being a princess.
And then Mercy makes me be like,
oh, I miss being kind of yandere.
But what I like about all of us is like,
we don't feel like we all can like do each other's niches.
Like, you know, like sometimes it means Dom,
sometimes Mercy's Dom, sometimes it means yandere.
Sometimes I see is like a little bit yandere.
Sometimes Azura is more Dom.
Like I remember Azura like said some like crazy stuff
on my stream that was like very Dommy
when during our collab stream with Emmy and Mercy.
And I was like, excuse me.
Sorry, I'm talking so fast, by the way.
I think I had caffeine.
So I'm like, I also feel really bad
because I feel like I talked a lot during the,
let me slow down.
Deep breath, sheepie.
I feel like I talked a lot during the collab.
So I'm sorry if I like talked over your Oshii
or what, then I'm sorry.
Don't hurt me.
Yep, God.
Kicking in.
Someone that will allow you,
so it's not a human.
I don't know guys, it's a human.
I'm super human as well.
I'm gonna get in, I'm gonna get in.
All I see is the beginning of multiple personality disorder.
It's gonna be great.
Oh my God.
Bunspeak, no, Bunspeak would be when I get a pyre.
When I get a pyre, when I get like this,
when I get Bunspeak, that's Bunspeak.
That's when I get a mulliness and I sound really cute.
What's next, loving girlfriend, Sheebie?
You kind of already gotten that the past couple days.
Oh my God, Eminem's a YouTuber now.
Rap got Sheebie in the house, yeah.
But yeah, you just carry the conversation.
Yeah, sometimes I like,
sometimes I have to tell myself if there's a silence,
like I can be comfortable in the silence.
Sometimes I feel like I need to fill a silence.
Sheebie popping off today.
I'm full of, I'm full of all the jokes, you know.
Are you happy you're at 8K subscribers?
Yes, it was such a pleasant surprise
that I noticed that this morning,
because only like yesterday or the day before,
I was at 7.7, so that the clip,
the debut stuff probably helped a lot in the collab stuff.
So I'm glad that you guys like me and enjoy me.
Like I said, and one of my goals was to get 10K subs,
and I'm literally almost close to that,
and it's surreal to me.
Younger me would be confused, but proud
of how I got 10K subs,
because I've always wanted to be, you know,
a YouTuber and stuff or a streamer,
and my dreams are coming true.
And I get to be a whore, like it's great.
Affectionate, you know.
But yeah, it'll be super cool.
I'm trying to think of what to do for 10K.
I think I was, I'm probably gonna do
another hand cam for 10K.
I was, or maybe like a hand cam ASMR,
but that'd be cool.
You guys can see the stupid shit that I do.
But yeah, I prefer to give me ideas for 10K
because I would love to celebrate that milestone with you,
but I'm so very, very, very thankful for all of you.
8K is a really big number to me,
and I just can't wait.
And it's funny, because like,
Strawny's like, just you wait,
just until you wait until I get you that 100K play button.
And I'm like, oh, don't say that.
Like, oh my God, like that just seems so surreal to me.
And like, you're doing great, Shabrowski.
You got to be a woe.
What's a woe?
Lovingly?
Oh, a woe.
Oh, I got you, me.
Very funny.
But yeah, and I'm proud of the other girls too.
Like, I think Strawny is about to hit 10K
or probably has hit 10K.
I noticed it when me and Emmy were watching her stream
and giggling like a bunch of maniacs that I was like,
oh, she's at 9.9.
So like, Strawny's about to hit 10K.
Emmy is past 10K.
Icy finally hit 10K, 6K.
And I'm like, we're all growing at a steady pace.
And I'm so proud of all of us in the hard work
that we're all putting in.
It really shows.
And then again, the algorithm works in mysterious ways.
So sometimes like, one of us lag behind,
but we like make sure we lift each other up
because like, I'll say it like, Corpo Unity,
like we are unified.
Like we want to support everyone.
Strawny at 9.9, 4K.
Oh, see, like very close.
Like she'll probably hit 10K by the end of the night
or like tomorrow.
So I'm just really happy.
I'm happy that Strawny's dream is coming true.
She's giving us a platform to lift up smaller creators up.
They usually wouldn't have certain opportunities
and they're happening and it's great.
Like she was telling us about other opportunities
we might be able to have in the future.
And I literally was like, what?
Like we could have that.
We could get this.
Like, are you kidding me right now?
Like what?
Yeah, I'm so thankful for the girls.
I'm so thankful for them.
They're so wonderful.
I was literally in college before everybody left.
And I was like, can I just say, I love you all.
And Mercy's just like, I love you too.
And one, Mercy's a very lovey person.
Oh my gosh.
I walked away to use the bathroom,
but I still had my headphones on.
And it was, and then I think like Amy and Strawny
also like stepped away to like get tea and stuff and water.
And I'm like just like sitting on the toilet
using the bathroom with my headphones on.
And I just hear Mercy talking to Icy.
And she's just like, hi, Icy.
And Icy's like, hi.
And then she's just like, I love you, Icy.
And Icy's like, I love you too.
And I'm just like laughing on the toilet
because they're so fucking cute guys.
I swear to God.
But yes, like we all very much love each other.
We're all very supportive of each other.
And it's really cool.
Like I was, I liked talking, cause I was talking to Amy.
I'm like, oh, what'd you got going on?
Like what do you want to, like projects you want to do?
She was telling me and I'm like, aw, sick.
And I love the opportunity.
Like I always look forward to all of our collabs and stuff
because I just, we're usually busy with our own like streams
or like working on stuff.
So it kind of stinks when we can't like sit
and talk with each other.
And I was kind of bummed
cause like I know Azura had to stream afterwards.
And I was like, I wanted to hang out with Azura too.
I miss Azura.
I'm going to hang out with her
and have her just make funny noises on call.
Cause that's what she does.
She just giggles and cackles and just goes,
she's like, a little maniacal.
I love her for that.
Yeah, we got to hang out a lot, lots today.
And it was really awesome.
It was really great.
I can't wait.
We get to hang out.
Well, technically we don't get to hang out tomorrow, sad.
Cause we have the watch along, but like,
I kind of want to like be in call with them.
I'm going to ask actually, can we all be in call together
and we do the watch alongs
and I'll react at the same time.
I think we are going to do that.
I don't know.
At last, cause that would be great.
I'm still in call.
Whoops.
Let me just, I forgot I was still in call.
Any one of them could have walked in and been like, hey.
Oh.
Yeah, we're already like trying to make plans
to like see each other and stuff.
A monthly Jen collab.
Yeah.
We try for, we aim for that.
We try to aim for a month and then we might do
of like all of us.
And then like sometimes like, like me and Mercy
just like kind of just like jumped in call together.
Like we had a collab with other girls from mythos,
but then we kind of hung out with each other.
And then I did the same thing with Amy today.
And like, I want to do that with Icy.
And I want to do that.
And I've done, I want to do that with Azura and Strani.
Like I haven't even gotten into a collab with Strani yet.
Like what the hell?
But we all like definitely, like I'll just like wake up
and look at our Discord chat.
And yeah, Mercy collab's happening next week.
Yes, yes, yes.
We're playing Super Bunny Man.
I look at my, the Discord general for our company.
And it's just a bunch of us.
We're all just like, I love you.
I miss you.
We're gonna hang out.
I miss you guys.
What are you guys doing today?
What's going on?
Oh, that's really tasty food you posted.
Oh my God.
Your cat's so cute.
Like it's, it's great.
We need the viewer house to be real.
Imagine that would be so fun.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It's just like, it's really nice to be a part of something.
And I didn't realize how much I wanted that.
Cause like I went into a company wanting to grow as a creator.
And I know, like I work well with others,
but I didn't know I would be so devoted and dedicated
to all the other girls.
I was just like, okay, am I gonna see them as coworkers?
And I'm like, no, I don't see them as coworkers.
I see them as very close friends.
Um, I know I'm bad when it comes to watching streams
of all kinds of everyone,
but generally I hope you all continue to grow and be happy.
I think we will.
And it's like, it's okay.
You don't have to like, you do what you can.
And we appreciate that.
We appreciate all of that.
How much do we need to donate to get the viewer house
to become real?
I think it would be way too much.
Viewer house turned into a battlefield by the pets.
Yeah, that's a good point.
We all have pets.
That'd be bad.
My cats would probably eat in these rats.
How are you doing?
I'm glad I can see my favorite bunny waifu.
Oh, thank you.
Hello, I'm doing really great.
I got to hang out with cute girls today
and I got to look at really awesome designs.
I really wish we could have done more.
Yeah, it does feel great to feel like you belong somewhere.
I've never like felt more meant to do something,
to be honest with you.
Like I am like, I am supposed to be here.
I belong here.
And like, I remember like hoping to the freaking universe
I got into Veealer and because I'm like,
I know I'm meant to be here.
And that's why I recorded my audition video
three days before auditions opened.
And I thought of all the possible questions
they may ask in the form so I could prepare
and send it in as fast as possible.
And that's why I was the first one
to submit my audition to the Veealer.
Veealer at her, so I need soundproofing in every room.
You're so right though.
Like all of us fucking just moaning.
Hi, she being fellow harem.
Hello.
I do really hope you all get many,
many years of streaming and growing.
Me too.
Like I am only thinking like,
this is only like the second month guys.
Like we're halfway through the second month
and I can't believe how much has happened and changed.
And it's all thanks to you guys.
Like what the heck?
My God.
But do you also belong to the October series?
No.
Oh.
Hi, hi, everybody coming in.
I was never into VTubers much
until I saw all of your debuts last month.
But now I'm glad I came and stayed.
I've had more laughs recently than I had in a while.
I'm so glad that all we want to do is make you laugh
and coom.
I love you and all of you are giggle sticks.
I think if I ever,
I think I'm gonna call it that from now on.
No, wait, no, but I really like the idea of Bible.
But giggle sticks is funny too.
I just think it's so funny.
That that happened.
Hold on, let me see.
Oopsies.
I didn't mean to go into the freaking,
I didn't mean to join another call.
Oh, my manager sent me my thumbnails for the month
and I'm like awkward
because we're doing a Twilight watch along next week.
And it's funny because it's just like me as like Bella
next to day, next to Edward.
Oh, so funny.
Well, as Vod say, oh, the Vod staying up.
I was kind of like talking to Emmy
and Emmy was kind of explaining to me
how like Vod limited stuff works
and she was kind of like showing me.
And I'm like, it's not,
as long as I don't get a strike, I think it's fine.
So I'm like, you know what, it's funny.
It's hilarious.
I'm leaving it up.
I'm glad you found something that was meant for you.
I know what I'm after.
There's some obstacles in between.
And for that, I hope to find something that clicks
like you did with the other.
Yeah, like it took some effort to get here.
Like I had to stream, I had to prove my worth.
You don't like, some companies will say like,
oh, you don't need any prior streaming service,
like experience, but you really do.
And so it is really recommended.
If you want to become a VTuber
and you want to join a company,
please stream for a little bit
because you might find out you don't like it
or it might not fit into your schedule
or it's not the type of lifestyle.
You might not be used to the hate or the positivity.
Like, you know, oh, thank you, Paul for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
What the heck?
My gosh, I'll forgive the Bible.
The script master should release a new
English translation of the Bible.
I agree with that.
Thank you so much.
You're so sweet.
Team Edward or Team Jacob?
Team Jacob.
Celebratory pod keeping gifts.
Oh, mad I'm putting in that work in a show.
It deserves success.
Thank you.
And I'm happy you guys are enjoying the work that I put in.
Should be the trolley deserve better into, oh, 100%.
Trolley deserve way better.
Are you kidding me?
I would hate my child if my child was, you know,
whatever that happened.
All that jazz.
What's a giggle stick?
I want you to look down in between your legs.
Um, and yet I guess, oh no.
We got touched again, bro.
Oh, we all know why Team Jacob don't look at me like that.
Shibi, can I ask the reason for why we can't give
the full memberships to the girls
and instead only the emotes here?
I, to be honest with you, again,
I'm not super familiar with YouTube,
but I think the idea is that only really dedicated people
will want to spend time with you in the membership streams
and they're the ones who watch all your streams
and know what you're about.
If kind of like anybody went into a membership stream
and they're kind of like, I don't know, like normie,
then they might like kind of be off put,
but like for example, like my tag stream,
a lot of people were thrown off by that.
And oh my God, no, it is still got missed, bro.
Thank you for the other.
Oh my God, what?
Thank you for the other 20 and another 20 by 30 to you, Paul.
Oh my God.
All right, here are my little PogChamp.
Shibi likes furries.
No, I don't.
Damn.
But I think, yeah, it basically makes it
so you do have to spend at least some money to attend.
Gifts still give you a nice discount.
Yeah, like you just pay the remainder.
But yeah.
Oh my God, why are you guys so nice today?
Thank you for the 10 gifts, what the hell, guys?
Oh, they're like really trying to help that bro out.
I want to see, did he get it?
Oh my God, he did it!
Bro, your settings must be off.
There can be no way.
There can be no way, you must have settings off
so you can't get this gifted.
Dodged.
Just a running gag.
There's always one person that just misses it.
Where's mine?
You have one, it's right there.
Oh, you guys are so nice.
You're like, let's get all green in here.
Or is a brand account?
That's a good point, it could be a brand account.
She be punishing me lovingly, thank you.
Punch the mic, punch the mic, punch the mic, punch the mic.
I think that's gonna be a bit now.
Sorry.
See, I'm punishing you lovingly.
That's loving, me punching you.
One day it'll work, what's a brand account?
I don't...
All right, round three.
Third time's a charm, thank you Paul.
I wanna see, I wanna see, is it gonna work?
Come on, speak.
The punches of love, oh no.
No, no, oh brother.
It's so shib over.
You probably only have to worry about the brand account thing
if your account is really old, that's a good point.
Okay guys, stop for real.
You gotta need to calm down.
Someone just paypal my bro like five bucks
and call it a day.
I'm getting soaked, oh.
Punch the mic, punch the mic, punch the mic.
No.
Oh my.
It doesn't end, okay.
You poor thing.
All right, chat, I'm taking you close to my chest.
I love you guys so much.
It's got you, your luck is just not good.
As I'm giving you a kiss, mwah, mwah.
Oh my god, okay.
Is this a game to you guys?
Oh my god.
Mwah.
Guys, guys, calm, the ward is, did he get it?
No, he still did.
Guys, this is, stop, stop, stop, stop.
The gacha needs to end, guys, stop.
Thank you, thank you.
On a gorilla stream.
Oh my god, thank you, hold on.
Let me say thank you.
Thank you, viewer lover.
Thank you, dragon and Dante.
And Dante, dragon and Dante.
Thank you, Paul, again.
Thank you, Joker.
Thank you, average amphibian.
You're not average.
You're great.
Thank you, Ken, at 30.
Oh my god.
You could be a lucky recipient
of a Shippee-Kan-Wambiola membership.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god.
Thank you, Usmami.
Next one.
Next one, did he get it?
Did he, no, no.
No.
I think it's an ultra rare, apparently I'm not eligible.
Okay, that explains a lot then.
Oh no, oh guys, see that's why I told you to stop
because I'm like, there's probably something else going on.
That's preventing him from getting one.
He must have a brand account then.
Oh, it was rigged from the start, guys.
No, you tried.
Thank you for the gifted.
That's why I was like, stop, stop.
Oh.
But congrats to everybody else who got gifted stuff
and now you can have my emotes.
My other emotes should be done at some point very soon.
Oh, the brand account debuff is real.
Thank you again, Joker.
You guys are absurd.
I guess this is like, you guys paying me
for the silly script that I read for you.
I'll have to split these with Emmy.
I'll be like, throw some money at her.
Just be like, there's your cut.
Yeah, you'd have to make a whole new account.
I don't care if I'm actually not eligible.
Oh, but you should probably get that checked out, bro.
And you get access to member streams, yes.
And then I have an archive karaoke
and when I come back from my vacation,
from the 18th to the 23rd,
and then we have a watch along on Monday.
What's the day?
Today's Saturday.
I have to go to my parents' house tomorrow.
So I get a suitcase,
because I forgot I don't have a suitcase.
Ooh, I got a sub, but doesn't tell me from who.
Yeah, say, make sure you say thank you.
Say thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
You will be green in madam's presence.
I was like, next time drinking is right.
Like if you don't, yeah, they're just emotes.
If you want to get an actual, you have to upgrade.
Oh my God.
Sorry, it's your favorite character.
My cat's food going off.
The gray harlot is still valid.
You're still appreciated and loved.
You still show up to my streams.
I still appreciate you.
As well as the Lurkers.
But yeah, we did a really fun tag list.
We watched Sucker Punch the other day.
It was really fun.
Yeah, so it's only a couple bucks.
I feel like I'm like shilling myself.
Check out my Patreon in the description below.
Check out Emmys' Patreon in the description below.
We'll actually go to her.
I don't think I have her Patreon
or any of the other girls' Patreon.
Um, go to her channel.
Stop to her Patreon.
That's all I'm gonna say.
I was once a gray harlot too, long time ago.
You were like, they were gray like five minutes ago.
My cats are eating.
Alphia is eating.
Hi, Pia.
Raina is asleep.
Raina is knocked out on the chair.
Raina, are you good?
Raina.
Raina, what are you doing?
Oh, you're licking your paws.
Okay, sorry.
And Boomi is knocked out on the cat tree.
He has passed out.
My little handsome man.
All his paws are all together.
He's very cute.
Just checking you're still streaming longer.
I don't know.
I was just talking.
I guess I'll stream longer.
It's only the least I can do
after getting a bazillion freaking gifted.
So yeah.
Where's Yappin?
Where Yappin?
You remember dogs and lizards over cats or reptiles?
Do I redirect her to you?
Yes, mom, you can.
Strani, I definitely recommend that you watch this VOD,
by the way.
At least like the first like 30 minutes to an hour
or like go through it
because you'll laugh because of me
and Amy did something funny.
Amy was on my stream.
Oh, thank you for the gift and Mr. Black's silence.
I've gifted Mr. Black's silence.
26, whose name makes me crack up every time I see it.
Well, I leave for 10 minutes and so many gifted.
Yeah.
People were trying to hit this one dude
with a gifted membership, but he moans
and then I think he just doesn't, he's a brand account.
Oh my God.
Very silly.
Okay, where is,
I feel like I need to make myself a little bit bigger.
I'm a little bit far away.
Let me get up close and personal.
With y'all.
Hi, welcome to my room.
Yes, I wear a sign on my shirt because YouTube hates me.
You know what? It's coming off.
A limiter coming off.
Everybody gets to see.
I'm not ashamed of myself anymore.
I am here to stay.
Imagine if I was flat, Tristan.
That'd just be weird.
But what if the justice,
I forgot to put my ooo-oo mouth on.
Wait, where'd my track go?
I want to see what you guys are saying.
She be on these.
YouTube hates body positivity.
I know, imagine my video just like disappears.
Cutting bird.
Well, I could take them off.
Actually, let me see if I can do that.
I think I could take them off.
Can I take them off my boobs?
I feel like this is a bad idea for me to try,
just like I did when I accidentally was changing
my skin color on stream.
Let's not do that.
I would, so I wouldn't remove that.
Like I wouldn't, it just,
I would just make myself transparent.
They would just be transparent.
So you guys would be able to see through me.
Shawty, Mama Raid.
Hello.
I hope you have your giggle sticks ready.
Cause we're about to shlorp, shlorp.
I'm sorry.
Oh my God, my headphones are dying.
Hi, writers.
Hello, Raiders.
Welcome in.
I have no idea where you guys are up through this stream.
You'll laugh really hard, mom.
You'll laugh really hard, Shawty.
If you watched like the first hour of it,
or a little bit less.
Is this the R greeting session?
We might have read the first script
and heavily censored it because of how silly it was.
Herm.
Did she win?
Was she winning?
Was she winning, Riftlands?
Did she win Baltaro?
Baltaro?
Was she winning?
Strony equals Shibi's top?
What?
I don't know.
Honestly, I don't know the power dynamic
between me and Strony.
Oh my God, here we go again.
Thank you a third of the time he gifted.
Jesus Christ.
He did so great.
I'm glad.
Remember to like and subscribe.
Have all three flinks to support Shibi.
Oh yeah, like and subscribe.
Also send that love over to Amy
cause she was on over here as well.
Don't forget to like, comment and subscribe.
On any of our VODs and streams,
just like at Strony's.
I can't even talk because people won't stop gifting.
Guys, relax.
Thank you to X2Doki for the 10 gifted.
My God.
The gotcha must flow.
It's literally like just like pull
and hope that you win.
Oh my.
Thank you for the 20 gifted Paul, but yeah.
Oh my God.
I'm so good at dodging.
You're good at dodging too.
Everybody's dodging.
Everybody's taught like all my Lakers
are poking popping up like did I win?
Hopefully.
Guys, at this rate, I'm going to literally
have only greenies.
No harlot left behind.
Yeah, everybody should be able to use the emotes.
Oh, you guys are so sweet.
I'm pretty sure I can get gifted membership.
It's just my luck, I guess.
It is very, very odd.
You know what?
I honestly don't care about getting a membership.
I'm just happy to support a Vtuber I like watching.
I don't even need a Vtuber.
Whatever guys, I don't need a membership from you guys.
Whatever.
No, but you're right.
I still appreciate you even if your name is gray,
even if you're a Laker,
as long as you watch and support me and the girls,
that's all that really matters.
Thank you.
Thank you, Average and Phibian.
Is this going to be a stream of me just saying thank you
for all the gifted?
Thank you, Average and Phibian for the 10 gifted.
Believe me more.
Plop, plop, plop, good gifted, good gifted, good gifted.
Sundare Chat, Sundare Streamer, it works.
Maybe I don't want a cool sticker.
Maybe I just want to be plain.
If it is when I'm out of here,
what do you mean?
Where are you going?
Get the fuck back here.
You don't get to leave.
You thought you could leave.
You don't get to go.
Oh, wait, guys, I've,
since there's a lot of you here.
Jay Santorillo.
Hey, welcome to the members, the members here.
Do you like my reverb?
Should we, should we start singing songs?
Hold on.
Where's my,
can I put on the cute and funny?
Hi, everybody.
It's me, British Stevie, once more.
Hello.
Thank you so much for all of the gifted subs.
You are also very sweet.
I appreciate you so much.
You've been reverbed.
Get reverbed, get reverbed, get reverbed.
As long as you don't start singing
the Darren Waller classic Cook On Shibs.
Oh, I'm Jeet Shibathani.
Hi, yes.
I'm Shibathani's British sister.
I'm not the older one that's in Britain.
I'm the younger one that's in Britain.
The older one sounds like this.
She talks like this.
Yeah.
Well, go on, Solar.
I never stopped working.
Let's see.
Let me think of a song to sing.
I need to put in my right headphones for this
because I'm using my different headphones.
I need to put in my IEMs for this.
Doing your shit, Britannia.
Oh, my God.
This fucking echo.
Echo, echo.
Sing me a song.
Wait, what's that song?
Let me take the echo down.
What's the viewer about?
Oh, Misty.
Whoa, my voice cracked.
How I just hurt my mouth.
It's like bumped my straw against my gum.
Ow.
Hi, Boomi.
Oh, thank you for that.
I was just a gifted because I'm so used to saying gifted.
The gifted, the gifted.
Boomi, why are you going in the box?
A viewer lover.
Thank you for the $5.
Dr. P, thank you for the 10 gift.
Guys.
You're absolutely fucking going bonkers right now.
How I'm the grafted.
Oh, my God.
It will never stop.
It's just going to be a constant stream.
Get spoiled.
God, I don't deserve this.
I don't deserve this.
Stop it.
Okay.
This song.
Hold on.
I need to look at the lyrics.
It goes out to Strawny.
I want to do this.
I want to, uh, I want to clap on this song with her.
I'm not going to put the music because then everything will just get claimed.
Oh, misty high up the mountain below.
Keep careful.
Watch off my brother's soul.
And should the sky be filled with fire and smoke.
Keep watching over do more in the sun.
If this is to end in fire, then we should all burn together.
Watch the flames cry high into the night.
Calling out father home.
Stand by and we will watch the flames burn hot burn on the mountain side.
I can't sing that well.
I'm sorry.
Strawny did it.
Wait, I wasn't looking at my chat.
I was looking at the lyrics.
Did Strawny just give fire?
Why did you give fire?
Thank you, Strawny.
Oh my God.
I'm living in a freaking cry at this rate.
So you guys are too good to me.
Strawny, do you want to collab with me on this song?
I think we could do a really good job.
And then later she's like, that'll be coming out of your paycheck.
No kidding.
This really is a member song.
I can't sing.
RIP broke my vocal cords.
We can like throw some auto tune on it.
Honestly, I love your memer song.
I'm just a memer.
Oh my God.
Thank you, Mr. Black.
I love fire.
I imagine, because you mentioned when you get rated,
I'm like minus $25 for kids.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah, that doesn't mean you can't.
It doesn't mean you shouldn't.
Exactly.
I just love Ed Sheeran's voice in that.
Waiting for the one person to drop 50 gifted.
No.
Stop it.
Get your hand away from that freaking button.
She does have a good voice.
I don't know what she's talking about.
Stop it.
Get some help.
Okay.
I'm not going to sing the whole song.
That's a little test.
Don't tempt fate.
Are the gifted part of my allowance?
Yes.
Sing yellow.
Oh, I like yellow.
Yeah.
And it was all yellow.
Yellow.
But I can't play.
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
It's a little bit too much.
I go more reverbs so I sound more ethical.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Okay, sorry.
Whoa.
Oh, I knocked something over my desk.
Look at the stars.
Look at the skies.
I'll put some autotune on and see if that helps me a little bit usually the autotune just actually makes my stuff worse
That's me see I
Need to pull up chat so I can see you guys on the slide. Oh my god. I just I didn't see it might know my god
key signal
Triangle 79 everybody with the 50 gifted
You still think I'm one of them. Oh my god, absolutely crazy
Dude I
Don't even have anything to say besides. Thank you. I just I didn't expect coming on that this would happen
I just wanted to be silly with Emmy and show you guys something funny and then talk with you guys and tell you how much
I love my gen mates, and then this happens. I
Want to see no more green names. Oh my god
That's why thank you guys seriously from the bottom of my heart again
I got to quit my job because of you and I can become a full-time streamer because of you
And I'm achieving my dreams because of you and I this I love you guys so much. Oh
My god
I don't deserve it. I really don't I don't are you trying to make me cry guys stop
Are you trying to make me fucking cry?
Thank you, Irene Reaper 1871
Thank you
Oh
I don't know what to say
Here's fake money
Oh my god, it began as a joke now it's a mission
You know, yeah, you better give this energy to the girls as well you better
Thank you for becoming a member
Oh
There's too many slices
You better give the same fucking energy to the other girls. I swear to god you better
I forgot it was on
You know what I noticed my tears don't run down my face anymore
But honestly, it feels kind of funny. I remember seeing a tweet of someone saying
It feels weird crying on stream and then putting on my crying toggle. I feel like I'm recording myself for a TikTok
Oh
Her new horse affection it could be so wholesome
I look real drisd. Oh rain is coming to cheer me up because she's like, why are you crying? Hi, Raina
Oh my god
Thank you as money for the 10 you deserve all the love and support
Raina on the mission
Everybody's gonna have emotes and I can't wait when I get more emotes because I can probably get more emotes now
I'm trying to sing for you guys and you guys you're being so nice. I'm supposed to be the dog
But
Again if you're gonna call me a bitch you better put sensitive in front of it
Oh
So you can take the money. What am I a stripper? Yeah, no
Hey
Like she's she be is crying play despacito
Despacito. This is how we do it down in Puerto Rico
Breaking the love down and love and support to adorable. Ah, no strong. He's seeing me cry
You're our stripper
Yeah
The she be love harem love. I'm your dog stripper. Okay
Wait, that makes me hold on. I'll sing yellow in a moment, but I'll I'll dedicate this song to you guys
Raina I need to put you in the bed so you can oh my god, my headphones fell out
Put my other headphones here. I'm sorry to set the microphone. I'm sorry if they're your ears. I'm a mess right now
Okay, this one is this for
The hair members
Because I'm your stripper
And I'm gonna do what a stripper does and sing which strippers don't sing but it's fine. It's just for the bit
I need the I definitely need the auto tune for this you need the auto tune
Okay, um, I'm debating whether or not just to make this like a mini karaoke
Um, I don't know where did wait, where did my chat go?
Chat where are you chat? This is real
Oh, thank you for the five gifted lover of fandom. Thank you for the 10. I look away and there's more gifted
Thank you to shine for 10 gifts. I don't
Have someone just did 100 super
Keep crying. I'm tears of joy. I don't know much to say so
Thank you. I'm happy to have all of you around
I'm crying at auto tune again
Ah
That's kind of funny chat. We're like chat
Okay, um
Thank you for the one gifted boy. He's like, I got something to say about this too
Everything helps that I am achieving my dreams. Thank you, scrawny for giving me such a wonderful audience
So I couldn't stream too like
They wouldn't have done this without scrawny shot out to scrawny
Raina's on my desk like rubbing against my my fucking monitor. She's like, yeah
What are you doing, Raina?
Lay right there. Come on
Oh
Um
Hey guys ready, I'm gonna play the background song. I don't care anymore
Get rid of my bgm
You guys are gonna laugh
I hope it makes you laugh
All right, Raina. I'm sorry. You can't keep walking on my desk. I have to put you in the ground
Okay, uh, let me
Uh
Karaoke
I
Just there at one. Well, I'm gonna mute the audio so you can't hear it
Oh my god ads
Hold on. I can't see chat right now. Please don't be sending me more stuff
Thank you. You have a bond for the 20
Continuing the she be cry fun. You've done more for me than I could ever express to you. I'm so glad to be
Doing some jobs for you so many times
Oh, thank you
Thank you right for chaos was fun
Whatever she be
Quick so like I could at all
Like I uh, I'm a very
I'm a very
Um affectionate living person and you guys don't know how much this means to me. I'm I'm a very sensitive person too
Yeah, I play a dom and whatever but like
Oh, this is too much for me
I'm crying in autotune
Oh
Oh wait, I need to switch this to the right headphones
Perfect, okay
You guys will like this one
I'm not gonna say the whole thing
Convict
Music
And you know we are front I see you winding and grinding up on the floor
I know you see me looking at you and you already know I want to love you
You already know I want to love you
You already know
Girl money in the air as mofield grabbing by the coattail taking to the motel wholesale
Don't tell no motel baby. Say I don't talk dog, but she told on me
Oh, well take a picture with me. What the flick on do baby stick to me and I'm a stick on you
If you pick me then I'm a pick on you do double g and I'm here to put this stick on you
This is right rip right in the poles and the doors is tight
Now I get me a shot for the end of the night because
Winding and grinding up on the floor
I know you see me looking at you and you already know I want to love you
Look you already know I want to love you
You already know
Girl shawty I can see that you ain't lonely and full of they all got cheese
So now you're looking at me now. What's it gonna be?
There's another tease for as I could see trying to get you up about this club
If it means spending a couple dubs throw about 30 stacks in the back make it rain like that because I'm far from a scrub
You know my pedigree xd yellow use men of means
Girl I spend money like I don't mean nothing but setting out a thing for you
I see you winding and grinding up on the floor
Now you see me looking at you if you already know
I love you love you you already know I want to love you
You already know
Girl
Wait, where did chat go? There you are
See you
Yeah
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Girl and while you're looking at me. I'm ready to hit up the catty right up to the patty
Oh move the patty to the catty. Maybe you got a fatty the type
I like to marry want to give you just everything and that's kind of scary because I'm loving the way you shake your ass
Founcing got me tipping my glass
Little Molly don't get cut up too fast, but I gotta thank for you. I see you winding and grinding
Up on the floor. I know you see me looking at you and you already know
I want to love you
Love you you already know I want to love you love you you already know
I love you
Can't see I'm doing heart hands right now
So let me see
Let me see
Ma'am. Oh hi Nori
Candy shop 50 cents. Oh, yeah, I could do that
With every stream you and the rest of you later helped me with my mental health and stress
I was going through a lot rough time in my life and you showed up in June. Thanks for the last
Thank you. Viola. Love her for the $10 super
I hope you're okay, and I'm happy that we can contribute to you being okay
I'm evidence of song
Oh my gosh, I'm so thankful for you guys. My mental health too. Oh shut up dude. We don't care about you. We don't care about primarily
Oh baby a triple. Oh baby a triple.
Oh tiny spiny tip three dollars and 33 cents
As I send this don't know I'm about an hour and 20 minutes behind since I wanted to watch the script reading
I'll catch up later. But thanks for the absolutely wheeze heavy stream
I'm glad you liked
Oh, this was a good stream. It's a good stream today
Even if we did it like the all the stupas are like the gifted or whatever. No, it doesn't matter to me
It's it's that you guys are having fun. That's all I care about
They've uncrustable. Uh, I like strawberry white bread my favorite
I haven't had Christmas in a very long time. I'm suffering guys. Okay
Uh
Whoa
Oh
Hey, oh, oh the fireworks are starting
Bro about to cry because fireworks are starting outside. But like in a good way. I feel like I'm celebrating something
Oh my god, I can look out my window and see them
Oh, they're so pretty that one was a heart that one was a heart guys. I'm gonna cry anymore
Oh, yeah, if you hear, uh, banging noises, I promise you it's not gunfire
It is fireworks because my my city's doing fireworks today
Uh
Oh my god, I'm on too
Oh, I accidentally put you guys the wrong thing crap. I can't see you guys hold on
I'm thrilled off
Okay
Oh my god another 20 gifted
Cute Paul, what the hell? I like I look away and then there's more gifted
Thank you flower head
That scared me
Love you. She be I'm being that proud to call you my oh
She
I'm here for the long haul me too. I'm here for the fucking long haul too. You guys have no idea. Am I drunk? No
I'm just an emotional woman. What did you expect?
I'm not drinking
I should be but that's a bad idea
No, nori, ha ha nori get membered get membered get membered nori get membered nori
All right
Yeah, so seductive
Oh, I'll take you to the candy shop. I'll let you lick the lollipop
Go ahead girl. Don't you stop. Keep going till you hit the spot. Whoa, I'll take you to the candy shop
Yeah, we got taste of what I got. Uh-huh. Have you spending all you got? Come on. You go until you hit the spot. Whoa
Can I have it your way? How do you want it? You go back? Why don't I remember the actual rap?
The next level
That's what you impact pot is tea kettle. I'll break it down for you now, baby. It's simple. If you be an info, I'll be an info
I'm telling the back of the rental. I'm a beacher in the park. It's whatever you're into
Got the magic stick. I'm a love doctor. Have your friends tease you about how I sprung
I got you. Want to show me how you work? Get baby. You'll probably get on top of the faster
Like a low rent. I can't do that
Bet you like the giggle stick
Uh, actually, I'll do yellow. Someone asked for yellow earlier
Thank you for the gift and authority
Thank you for the 10 gifted average guys. Stop
This bunny a freak. She a freak. She a freak. I'm a freak
Uh, karaoke
Uh
Where is this person's that's the scientist that's not what I'm looking for
Oh my god, shut up. Sorry
Big stop means go no
Going out. I don't know that song. Oh wait, I do know that song
I don't know if I can sing that though
Freak
I'm a freak
I'm a freak. I'm just a fake ass freak. I'm sorry guys. It's true. I'm a freak
You guys found me out. I don't know what to do
S&M by Rihanna. Oh
Yeah, that's a good one
$5 leave it you can leave the door open
I sound like you you do. Yeah
Hi, everybody. I'm nori. Hi everybody. I'm noriko. Yes. Hi. I'm nori. Hi. I'm nori
Hi
She's frightened
Thank you for the thank you
Look at the stars. Oh no, look how they shine for you
And everything you do
Yeah, they were all yellow I came along and wrote a song for you
And all the things you do
And it was called yellow
Check the auto tune off took my turn
I totally lost my spot have done
And it was all yellow
Oh
Your skin oh, yeah, your skin involves turning
To something beautiful
Do you know you know, I love you so
You know, I love you so
Oh
I need a microphone
Microphone microphone microphone microphone
Yeah, this is fucking huge. I'm still crying in my toggle
I'm blushing
Sorry, I'm not looking at this
Oh, what a thing
Because you were all yellow drew a line I drew a line for you
Oh, what a thing to do
And it was all yellow
Oh
That's my giggle stick on the mic
Your skin oh, yeah, your skin involves turning
To something beautiful
And you know for you I bleed myself dry
For you I bleed myself dry
Yes, I'm holding the mic with my boobs leave me alone
Oh my god, thank you for the members skog stomp them
Thank you for that wait everything I think I get yeah, yeah, okay. I just want to make sure I say thank you people
It's true
Look how they shine for you
Look how they shine are you I can go to high look how they shine
Look how they shine
At the stars look how they shine for you
In all the things that you do
Param
Yeah, so professional streamer sets up their mic
All right, are you guys ready to party? Oh ignore that
uh
I'm about to belt. I think everybody's probably outside on their balcony is watching the um
Fireworks, I don't have to worry about that. How are my cats doing?
Hold on. Let me go check on my cats. I don't want them to be scared
Okay, Rena's good
Everybody
All right, they're actually doing okay, and I'm doing better than I thought this is their fourth first fourth of july
So I just want to make sure that they're good. Well, it's not for the July anymore, but you guys get it
okay
cats going um
My fire alarm used to go off a lot because my neighbors were stupid and they would accidentally set off the fire alarm
And I'm building and so the cats are very scared of all loud noises now, which makes me very sad
Again, I also apologize that you can hear the fireworks in the background
All right, are you ready?
We don't need to hear the part
Oh
Wait, I was like it was like just beeped randomly
Na na na come on na na na na come on
Na na na na na come on come on come on come on
Oh
Na na na na come on
I don't know. There's so many na na na's of the song
Come on. Come on. Na na na na
Feel so good being bad
There's no way I'm turning back
Now the plane is my pleasure because nothing could measure
Oh
Love is great. Love is fine
Out of the box out of line
The affliction of feeling leaves me wanting more
Because I might be bad, but I'm perfectly good at it's sex in the air
I don't care. I love the smell of the sticks and stones may make my bones my chains and whips
Excite me. Oh my god. I might be bad, but I'm perfectly good at it's sex in the air
I don't care. I love the smell of it
Oh my how does she have so many pipes and make my bones my chains and whips excite me
I
Like I like it. Come on. Come on. I like I like it. Come on. Come on. I like I like it
Come on. Come on. I like I like it
Love is great. Love is fine
Out of the box out of line
The affliction of the feeling leaves me wanting any to take a drink
I have autotune on I'm not hitting the notes
Perfectly good at it's sex in the air. I don't care. I love the smell. This is what I sound like without autotune
May break my bones by chains and whips excite me
Oh come on. Come on. I like I like it
I like I like it. Come on. Come on. Come on. I like I let you real singing
You like it like it
s s s and m m m s s s and
m m m
Oh
I'm but the love the feeling you bring to me. Oh you turn me on
It's exactly what I've been yearning for
Give it to me
Even in my bedwa make my body say
I like it because I might be bad
Sex in the air. I don't care. I love the smell of it sticks and stones may break my bones by chains and whips excite me
Oh, I need to breathe for a moment
I
Care I love the smell of it sticks and stops may break my bones by chains and whips excite me
Hey somebody knock on my door. Oh, no, it's just fireworks
I thought someone went knock knock
I like I like it. Come on. Come on. Come on. I like I like it s s s and
m m m s s s and
m m
Hair hair um
Why is this crazy woman singing?
Oh, rihanna was trying to spell s and m. I finally kept pretending
A decade. Can you keep it down? We're trying to listen to the fireworks. Oh, shut up. Add
I don't have an ad blocker one of it
Oh, wait, wait, wait, I got you guys. I got you
You
How can you see into my eyes?
Like open doors
Leading you down into my core
Where I've become so numb
Without a soul
My spirit sleeping somewhere cold until you find it there
Back
Home yep
Home wake me up. Wake me up inside can't wake up wake me up is a save me
Call my name and save me from the wake me up
Bend my blood to run can't wake up before I come on to save me save me from the
Nothing I become
Sorrow wake up sora wake up
Can't what if you guys don't know look up look up bring me to life by goofy and thank me later
Because someone in cosplays has him out there singing this song
Well save me
Oh
Miss morrigan tipped four dollars and twenty cents she be do you know martyr by king mala?
I do not
It would also really suit the domi vibe. Oh, I don't we're not singing like domi songs. We're just singing
We're just singing anything
If I know this song, I'll try to sing it. I think hold on. I had more another don't know
Thank you guys for the donos. My god
I
Did not expect a goofy script reading girl stream
To turn into overwhelming you with love karaoke and fireworks, you know, and I think you she'd be I know very, you know
I have to burp. I'll give you a free burp
There you go with the with the with the reverb on
Not like us music or fast. I don't know what that means
What do you mean by that joker thank you for the five dollar tip though and thank you for the tip miss morrigan
Did not
Hey, you by Barry Lipman
You guys think I know more songs than I actually do. I'm not that cultureed
Sounds like something's moving in your vents. It's the fireworks outside. Oh
Oh
Wow those hold on I want to oh my god guys. It's so pretty. Okay. Hold on. I'll be right back. I'll take a picture for you
I'm gonna record
Actually, wait. No, you guys will freaking do something weird about it. I'm gonna take a picture though
Probably try to help me down
Maybe turn the lights off
So I can take a picture
Oh
Wow
Okay, I'm coming back
Let me turn it way back on payment. I wanted to picture that was cool
Watching fireworks with madam
Calculate. I know I'm like, let me not talk to myself. I think it ended on
Perfect note. Okay. Um, let's see. Let's see. Somebody said one that I liked
Wait, duh. Of course we have to sing this song
We have to sing this song
And I can't hit the note so bear with me the auto tune is gonna be on
I don't think I could turn down the auto tune. I can more fit more
More for all. Hi
Hi
Hello
Sound like balloon boy. Hello. Hi. Hello. Sorry. Okay. Anyways
Crazy frog ding ding. I used to be obsessed with the crazy frog when I was younger. Um
Ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
Uh, boomie, can you move? Thank you
Hello
That's so creepy
Okay, did anybody don't know when I was walking away?
Okay. No, thank god. They finally stopped. Okay. Um, here we go
Hey, I'm math and a little we don't care
Shut up. Male discussing
Yeah, boomies boomies chillin
That's a weird thing to say
Do you ever feel like a plastic bag drifting through the wind wanting to start again
Do you ever feel feel so paper thin like a house of cards when blown from caving in
Do you ever feel already buried deep six feet under screams, but no one seems to hear a thing
Oh, yeah, I forgot my phone
There's still a chance for you
It's working here. You just gotta ignite
I'm not hold on. I need to start over when we just hopped on my desk again
Hold on. I'm gonna do better. Hold on. I promise you. I'm better. I'm better than this
The voice crack though
You just gotta ignite
Oh
They let it shine
Just on the night
Like the fourth of july
Cause baby you're a firework
Come on show him why
You're worth
Make him go ha ha ha
As you shoot across the sky
Baby you're a firework
Come on let your colors burst
Make him go ha ha ha
You're gonna leave him all in ha ha ha
Your singing is too good for autotune. I know the autotune is not working properly
It's not gonna be too good though
Cannot be replaced if you only knew what the future holds
After her dream comes around. Oh my god, boonie, please
He keeps hopping on my desk
Over the leaves you to the perfect room
Like the lightning bolt
Your heart will grow
And when it's I turn off autotune, you'll know you just gotta ignite
The light
It let it shine
Just on the night
Like the fourth of july
Cause baby you're a firework
Come on show him why
You're worth
Make him go ha ha ha
As you shoot across the sky
Baby you're a firework
Come on let your colors burst
Make him go ha ha ha
You're gonna leave him all in ha ha
Ha ha
Even brighter than the moon moon moon moon
It's always been inside of you you you
And now it's too time to land
I'm running out of breath
Cause baby you're a firework
Come on show him why
You're worth
Make him go ha ha ha
As you shoot across the sky
Baby you're a firework
Come on let your colors burst
Make him go ha ha ha
You're gonna leave him all in ha ha ha
Boom boom boom
Even brighter than the moon moon moon
Even brighter than the moon moon moon moon
moon moon
I was for you harem
Now that was for all Vila fans
That was for all of y'all I love you all
That's what you guys say
I am
Oh my god Paul Martt no
Do you mind if I clip you singing?
This needs to go viral to it
Sure you can clip me singing I don't mind
Oh thank you
Oh speaking of boom boom boom
Hold on I got you
Sorry now I feel like doing my own songs
You guys know this song?
I'm gonna sing this in my oo oo voice
Whoa whoa
Oh my god name water
Yeah what you k time
Whoa whoa
If you're alone and you need a friend
Someone to make you forget your problems
Just come along baby take my hand
Only you love her tonight
Whoa whoa
This is what I wanna do
Let's have some fun
What I want is me and you
Boom boom boom boom
I want you in my room
Let's spend the night together
From now until forever boom boom boom boom
I wanna go boom
Let's spend the night together together
In my room
I just realized I sound like Emmy
What I'm doing that voice
Wait a second
That's funny she's hearing spirit
You just realized this song
Boom boom boom by Vanga Boys
I think cause my throat is strange so it's a little bit different
This is what I wanna do
Just have some fun
What I want is me and you
Boom boom boom boom
I want you in my room
Let's spend the night together
From now until forever boom boom boom boom
I wanna go boom boom
Let's spend the night together
Together in my room
Boom boom boom boom
I wanna be in my room
Let's spend the night together
Boom boom boom boom
I wanna go boom boom
Let's spend the night together
Together in my room
Boom boom boom
Man this is the Wendy's
Instrumental
Mmm mmm get it
Get it get it
Throw it back come on Harim throw it back
Work on it work on it Harim
Go on
Let's break
Report the giggle stick
It's so unfair Harim
I'm trying
I'm trying to throw it back madam
Alright one more time let's go
Boom boom boom boom
I want you in my room
Let's spend the night together
From now until forever boom boom boom boom
Boom boom boom boom
I wanna go boom boom
Let's spend the night together
Together in my room
Boom boom boom boom
I want you in my room
Let's spend the night together
From now until forever boom boom boom boom
I wanna go boom boom
Let's spend the night together
Together in my room
Let's go
Ah Mario
I'm trying to kill bosses in it
No you can throw it back
While you're killing bosses don't lie to me
I can twerk and play games at the same time
Why can't you get on that
Take on me
Ooh I can try take on me
Never wanted to dance by MSI
Oh guys you guys are giving me really good ones
Yes you can stop throwing it back
Alright
I'll do the one
That people will probably know more
Which is
I'm stunlock and she hasn't even used the taser
I'll do take on me
Did somebody say
What does taser sound like
With reverb
Ow that hurt my ears
Ow that does not sound good
I don't like that at all
I almost tased myself
That's awkward
Anyways don't worry about that
We're fine
My neighbors are running by
With their little loud children
E E electric shock
Na na na na na
Sorry
A lot of students laser
Oh it's just reverb right now and a little bit of echo
Echo echo
Hello hello hello
Hello E E
Almost pulled into me
I have my
shock collar
Maybe I'll use my shock collar for 10k
Subs
I think I made it
Hold on let me get some more water
Since I'm singing now
I only had like a little bit
I'm looking at you
Are you crazy
I'm so crazy
I'm taking my salt water
You don't have to run over here
It's not fine for treats, ma'am
We've got 8 or 2 over there
Alright
Thank you for stopping by
Have a good one
It's electric
Woogie woogie woogie
You can't see it
It's electric
Woogie woogie
But as you know it's a
Na na na na na
It starts singing Cupid Shuffle
Cupid Shuffle
Down down
Sorry
Let's see I can try take on me
Let's try it
It's a lower key version
Probably better doing that one
Building your online business
No I'm not
Well technically I am
Because I'm a streamer
Cha cha real smooth
I know
You guys know it's Wix
You guys know it's so Wix
Calling it lower level
She be more she sing stop it
Look at all this shut up
I skipped it guys
Take a sippy
Actual boobs are like bouncing
When I'm trying to do this
You're talking away
I don't know
What I'm to say
I'll say it anyway
Today's another day
To find you trying away
I'm a little bit off
I'll be coming for your love okay
Take on me
Take me
On
I'll be
Gone
In a day or
Two
So needless to say
I'm on
Oh my god I've lost like
I lost train
I want to train my
I can talk
Say after me
It's no better to be safe than sorry
Take
On me
Take on me
Take me
On
Take on me
I'll be
Gone
In a day or
Two
That's so hard
Everybody's like two
Please sing any gorillas song like I love the gorillas
Actually
Actually I might do
Um
It's a good gorillas song
Take on me
Take me
On
Take on me
I'll be
Gone
In a day or
Two
Take me
On
I'll be
Gone
In a day or
Two
Sorry to keep hitting that note
Take on me
Take me
On
I'll be
Gone
In a day or
Two
Take
On me
Take on me
Oh my god
That's so hard
In a day or
Two
Take
On me
What the fuck is happening
Grammarly
Go away
How's that doing
Oh
I could do Mel and Collie Hill, something with a gamer myself.
Oregon tipped $13.37.
Thank you, Morgan.
This stream is the happiest I've been in months.
Oh, I'm so glad.
You're existing and sharing a part of yourself with us.
Of course.
I also really want to give you a hug
to show you how much I appreciate this for being you.
Thank you, Morgan.
I'm going to cry if you hug me, I'll cry.
Yay.
I want to give you guys all a big hug.
Thank you.
You guys give me lots of love.
I'll do a little bit of rap for you.
So we'll do, because I like to rap, I'm going to do gorillas.
Feel good.
No, Clint Eastwood, sorry.
Because I actually, actually know the rap for Clint Eastwood.
Let's see, let's see, let's see.
I like how this is turned into just like a pseudo karaoke.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
You know what I should do to make this ambiance a little bit
better?
Yeah, now, halt on.
I got you.
I got you so, so good.
Did it do good, wait.
Let's see.
I don't have like woosh or whatever or shoest, but this is fine, right?
What?
You have a small peepee?
I can't believe it.
No, I'm kidding.
I love that effect.
It's so funny.
OK, that's fine.
Let me do a little bit of lighting.
Oh, hi, Rena.
You're going to set the mood, yeah.
Oh, I'm big.
I'm trying to scroll through the chat.
MSI, maybe MIT MSI.
I killed it.
Thank you.
Dare.
I do love dare.
It's coming out.
It's that.
Oh.
You've got to press it on you.
You just think that's why you do, baby.
Hold it down there.
Ignore that side.
It's fine.
Now it's better.
I wish I could darken my room.
Can I?
I don't think I can.
Filters.
Change of fact.
Color correction.
Opacity black.
Close.
Yeah, baby.
Oh, yeah.
That can actually be really funny.
To recreate the dare music video.
That's actually good.
I used to drive from the boys.
I don't think I could do that glamorous or furky, perhaps.
Listen to the single.
Listen to the music.
Sing with me.
Oh, I love that.
All right.
I'm sorry guys.
I won't be able to do all the suggestions, but I'm trying to get through a lot of them
because you guys have a lot of good ones.
It's getting way closer to technique.
That was weird.
Sorry.
The way it started like, hold on.
I think we'll laugh.
All right.
Hold on.
Feel good.
I know this is feel good.
I want to clean Eastwood.
What am I doing?
That's better.
I was like, wait a second.
Oh, I ain't happy.
I'm feeling glad I got sunshine in a bag.
I'm useless, but not for long.
The future is coming on.
I ain't happy.
I'm feeling glad I got sunshine in a bag.
I'm useless, but not for long.
The future is coming on.
It's coming on.
Finally, someone let me out of my cage.
Now, time is for me for nothing because I'm counting no age.
Now, I couldn't be there.
No, you shouldn't be scared.
I am good at repairs and I'm under each snare, each tangible.
But you didn't think so.
I command you to panoramic you.
Look, I'll make it all manageable.
Pick and choose, sit and lose all your different crews.
Chicks and dudes who you think is really kicking tunes.
Picture you getting down in a picture tube.
Like you lift the fuse.
You think it's fictional, mystical, maybe.
Spiritual, hero who appears in you to clear your view when you're too crazy.
Lifeless, but to those who definition for life is priceless to you
because I put you on the hype shit you like it.
Done smoking righteous with one token.
Psychic among those possess you with one dose.
Breathe.
Useless, but not for long.
The future is coming on.
I ain't happy.
I'm feeling glad I got harem in a bag.
I'm useless, but not for long.
The future is coming on.
Is coming on.
The essence, the basics.
Without it, you make it.
Allow me to make this childlike in nature rhythm.
You have it or you don't.
That's a fallacy.
I'm in them.
Every sprout and tree.
Every child piece.
Every cloud and sea.
You see with your eyes.
I see destruction and demise.
Corruption and disguise from this fucking enterprise.
I'm sucked into your lies.
We wrestle not as muscles, but percussion he provides for me as a guy.
Y'all can see me now because you don't see with your eye.
You perceive with your mind.
That's the inner.
So I'm a stick around with Russ and be a mentor.
That's a few rhymes.
So motherfuckers remember what the thought is.
I brought all this so you can survive when law is lawless.
Feeling sensations that you thought was dead.
No squealing.
Remember that's all in your head.
I ain't happy.
I'm feeling glad I got sunshine in a bag.
I'm useless, but not for long.
My future is coming on.
I ain't happy.
Feeling glad I got sunshine in a bag.
I'm useless, but not for long.
My future is coming on.
It's coming on.
like a sip while this is happening he says it's coming on a bunch me coming
on here what coming hair I'm coming on me what wait someone don't know but I
can't hear it over the music this carabit song I don't know if I could
sing that one maybe I think I have one song I could sing I don't know like I
would usually remember like really like parts of songs like sometimes I don't
remember a full song because it's up to me I'd be like
but I don't know the whole song so I can't sing it I'd be crooning to all of
you right now I'm raising you up I'm gonna say Bible Bible Bible I'm gonna say
Bible say season one maybe I'll do a MSI song I want to get hype
I will study what I'm happy you guys like the radio sound and I was like oh
sweet cool we throw this in there I mean a karaoke bar with a real touch in the
back all the possibilities
guys I don't I don't think I can guys I can't I don't need a challenge I'm not
good at singing I'm just I'm okay
I should be I was raised the most I could stream started
I'll tell you the most common MSI song which is shut me up this is why this is
what I've sung when I was fighting um let me turn the echo down when I was
fighting Godric
is there karaoke for this oh there is
pushing it bang
there
the bass the rock the mic the treble I like my coffee bag just like my metal with the bass
the rock the mic the treble I like my coffee black just like my metal because I can't wait
for you to knock me up in a minute minute in a fucking minute I can't wait for you to knock
me up in a minute minute in a second I can't wait for you to shut me up and make
me hip like badass I can't wait for you to shut me up shut it
I can't wait for you to shut me up and make me hip like badass I can't wait for you to
Shut me up.
Shut it up.
Oops.
La, la, la, ooh, la, la, la, ooh, la, la, la, ooh.
The bass, the rock, the mic, the treble.
I like my coffee black just like my metal with the bass.
The rock, the mic, the treble.
I like my coffee black just like my metal
cause I can't wait for you to see me
in a minute, minute, in a fucking minute.
I can't wait for you to feel.
In a minute, minute, in a second
I can't wait for you to shut me up and make me
hip like badass.
I can't wait for you to shut me up.
Shut it!
I can't wait for you to shut me up and make me
hip like badass.
I can't wait for you to shut me up.
Shut it up!
Y'all better be moshing right now.
I want you throwing yourself around in your room.
I want you throwing up your hands,
I want you punching each other,
I want you fucking each other,
I want you fucking ass, right?
I'm fine, I'm fine right now.
Just want my money, my money, my money.
Hold on, I need to take a drink.
I'm fine right now.
Wait.
I don't find it funny right now, right now.
Just want my money, my money, right now.
I'm on the way to my party right now,
because don't break.
Don't break, don't break, don't break.
Can't wait for you to shut me up and make me
hip like badass.
I can't wait for you to shut me up.
Shut it up!
I can't wait for you to shut me up and make me
hip like badass.
I can't wait for you to shut me up.
Shut it up!
Please, I have a medical condition.
I have a medical condition.
Oh, that's good.
I was like moving around so much,
I need to crack my back.
All right, I need a softer song for my voice.
Where do you girls have evidence of this new book?
Sorry, sellers.
I'm wishing, I'm wishing for the one I love
to find me, to find me today.
Find me today.
I gotta go take some music, thank you.
Oh, hi Toma!
Hi!
Hi Toma!
My love, Toma.
Ready, ready, ready?
Toma, Toma, Toma, Toma, Toma, Toma.
What? What? What? What?
What does it mean?
Dumb Girl Failure Madam. You deserve the very best and I'm happy to get the opportunity
to spend time with you Tilva.
Oh, aren't you fun?
Anonymous tipped four dollars and twenty-
Guys, thank you Doki for the big tipped. I'll take all the tipped. I'll go all the
down to the base, thank you, thank you and all the best for the tip as well you guys are so sweet
oh wait what the hell this song came out recommended next okay i have to sing this song
i'm sorry you'll like it though don't worry we're going all over the world with our uh
all over the genres you guys are the best oh my god i can't even
mr worldwide i just have a lot i have a wide range of music i like you guys will like this song
you like this song i love this song i sing this in the car all the time
yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
oh my voice is cracking hold on i need a moment i'm so sorry i was like so ready but my voice
cracked hold on let me take some water i love it's so hype when you start the song oh i also
have to echo way up let me turn that down i'm so sorry
yeah i'm a little i'm a little this might not be as good the crack you kind of nailed that
you can hear my voice crack when i hum that's how i know my voice is going out
hmm i love my trick
oh yeah
oh no
hello again friend of a friend i knew you went
and our common goal was waiting for the world to end now that the truth is just a rule that you
can burn you crack the whip shape shift and trick the past again i'll send you my love on a wire
my voice is starting to go you up every time everyone
pulls away
yeah
got balls of steel got an automobile for a minimum wage
got real estate i'm buying it all up in outer space
now that the truth is just a rule that you can burn
you crack the whip shape shift and trick the past again send you my love on a wire
lift you up every time everyone
oh
it's a mechanical for the number one you'll take a ride from anyone everyone wants to ride
and pulls away
oh
what is sinister x i don't know that
we love you shamer i love you harem
oh wait no my chemical romance calm down i don't know if i can hit a lot now shabani shabani
might need to play through that
all right i think i can do one song for my voice i will let you speak amongst yourselves
i don't know if i could sing that one but thank you for the recommendation
oh
it's a lot of that oh my gosh reina hello
reina just really wants to snuggle right now
i do like kovinsky but i don't think i can sing that i can i'm gonna attempt golden hour
but i it's an attempt it's not gonna be it excuse me i barbed um so it's not gonna be like full
songs reina stop licking my elbow uh
first i need to listen to it
oh
sorry
tequila
uh
oh i think i know the lyrics to this
it was just you lovers sitting in the car listening to blonde falling for each other
pink and orange guys feeling super childish no tunnel lover i love tunnel lover mr call from
my mother like for us and i got no alibi i was all alone the love of my life she's good
i literally only know like the first few lines
this song is gorgeous though
i don't need to know like to see you shine
it's your golden hour yeah i see i can't i can't go my voice is fucked right now
there's a girl from aurora v uh aurora live vr who like seraphina oh i love her cover of the song
it's amazing this is america don't catch you tripping on i love i could rap for you whatever you
guys want the fuji cozy version i feel like i've heard that one too chop suey
i don't know why when i you said chop suey i thought of maximum the hormone for some reason
and i thought of uh i don't know why that song popped into my head i'm not doing that one
chop suey
that would be amazing if system of down covered that that would be actually amazing
guys if you don't come up with something i'm just gonna sing childish gabino i'm just gonna rap
um given you as the world caves i don't know that song i'm sorry
barbie girl chop suey please
rap adam childish gabino works funky town all star eight girl what's eight girl
just the two of us
make eater for metter keel solid three i don't know that so i know that like i know the song but i
don't know the song bring me to life didn't i just sing that no i sing woke wake me up
oh isn't that bring me to i don't work next episode ever long that's good one
no eight girl if i heard it probably
i know for this it's emotion city please don't hate me i don't know when somebody thought you
could hear my voice this way
you a girl by mgk no careless whisper i never want to dance again something something's got no
rhythm it's easy to pretend i know you're not a fool should have been no better than the gene
print kiss from a rose
i don't think i could go that high right now you would not believe your eyes if 10 million
fireflies something something i'll see a song up above your head madem deep throating under your bed
crystal ball was hanged just by a thread i'd like to make myself believe
something from avalavine oh girlfriend
doing what under my bed should be please what do you mean
i gotta sing most 90s song i can think of
shawty have them apple bottom jeans boots wait no i think that's 2000s
i sit in the bed i think in park boots what's the fur yes you don't
hey now you're an all star get your fame get your game on go play hang out you're a rock star
oh
you think i could do don't stop believing at this rate no
you have too much belief in me to be able to do that song right now
i'm holding up for a hero i did that the other day i did i sang holding up for a hero for emmy
i need an emmy
all the small things 2005 oh i love 2005 bro 2005 was my favorite song by childish campino
can't stop me now guys you you think i have way better vocals than i actually do
black cats and voodoo dolls oh i just
yes i just don't stop believing you all hexagram by deaf tones i don't i don't think i could do
deaf tones i would do fk twigs if that was like the first song i started with
like it's i hit it's hard to go that hard i love fk twigs
i'm number five classic disney song the thong song that thong the thong thong thong
ocean avenue tequila i'm dot the sea i could if you guys think of a disney song i'll do a disney song
for you you've seen her live oh my god i've always wanted to see her live i literally love fk
twigs so fucking much you're haunted let's do it around in my pony
today by smashing pumpkins i do like smashing pumpkins
k flay i know who k flay is oh my god there's like one song i do like by k flay i can't remember
what it is though something from Aladdin from the lips of an angel i i have a tendency to mimic
the singer's voice howdy shebe we love you i love you too everybody wants to be a cat
sing help no i've tried to sing hell fire from hunchback a disney karaoke i've done before and i was
so trash oh we don't talk about bruno seven foot frame racks along his back when he calls
your name it all fades to black son of a man son of man hell fire is so good
got friends on the other side that's also a good one
tap into the inner white girl and let it go guys come on let it go let it go i am one with the
wind and sky wherever it goes hi boomie aww you want a headbutt aww thank you for the head
that sounds weird thank you for the headbutt
you're a hero he faced on your screams
oh service pressure i'm the strong one i'm the something that song is such a bop
a good amount of break stuff
oh boomie hi bring me why is your face look mushed like that i'm gonna squeeze it
i can't do this to the light every day we're shuffling pump pump pump pump pump pump
oh i'm the king of the swingers oh the jungle vip i've reached the top and had to stop and
that's what's bothering me i want to be a man man come and go right into town and be just like
the other men i'm tired of mucking around oh who we do i want to be like you i want to walk like you
talk like you too i like that song yeah oh treasure planet i watched it the other day
i was like people were talking about it and i wanted to watch it
goofy ah boomie poison by the bell de veau i don't know why i thought of that girl is poison is
that this that's not for the same person poison didn't didn't poison
it is that one okay i'm sorry it's hollow butt girl and that you were talking shit and didn't
think that i would hear it people saying you're talking right back and everybody caught up i don't
know if i could treasure planet watch along soon i just watched it so it maybe maybe a little bit
longer at some point hey hey you you i don't like you got no i couldn't do girlfriend
who is jamira quiet you want to kill me with sense you've been gone
since you've been gone i can't breathe while i'm far star
i don't i'm sorry please don't hurt me
skater boy he was a skater boy she says see you later boy i saw the the cover of that by uh what's
her name oh my god it's gonna bother me she sings daisy i'm crazy but you like that i'll buy
back daisies on your nightstand never forget it lost a man i want mercy to cover that song
ashneko yes i love ashneko i don't know why i couldn't remember
return off the mic once again you always sounds funny to me
ah dracula no that'll fuck up my throat
yeah i feel like mercy would be so good for ashneko
i'm gonna eat her by hollow notes
i was listening to uh i think it's a remix fit featuring ashneko it's called pancake
i just want to ride right now i'm the sauce and spaghetti get you on it kind of heavy listen
to me in the country boy i finish every do me right and do me never
but is it the megan the stallion song i actually haven't listened to that full song
white rabbit shake that two to the one to the one to the three i might have outfitted
shake that ass for me shake that ass for me
head phone
say right i'll wake up feeling like you won't play right
i can't feel the love but i don't know the lyrics
and they can't hold away my right
if you want it
if you want
boomie what's up you don't have to jump on my desk
like please get off the computer mother please get off the computer ram ranch
18 naked cowboys in the showers at ram ranch and i don't want to miss a thing you think i can
sing bonfire off the me well i can sing i can rap bonfire i would i would rap it for real for
real no censorship if i had a tan talk right now
boomie wants to hear my singing
dancing by myself
you guys are giving me really good time i'm also just kind of like waiting
because i'm listening to you guys they're like seeing what songs you like
the moccarena friday i happened at the last stream it was just me um i just was farming
for four hours so i didn't really see a point in keeping it up sweet dreams are made of these
who am i to disagree want to be nice girls nothing but a cheat thing
guys i said disney songs i do like i'll make a man out of you okay here let me do a poll so be
because i'm a decisive as well so give me this disney songs maybe what's my name from disney
descendants i've seen descendants i don't know the music from them excuse me it's like i saw
your toggle and you started talking with your brother's gooning vr headset uh sorry you might
be thinking about shebethany that's not me yeah i love sweet dreams are made of me
who am i she sounds so ethereal ethereal a whole new world a dazzling place i never knew
i'm also stalling so i can like drink water uh what disney song
so i'll do make a man out or be a man whatever that's called
impossible intro call me beat me if you want to reach me
what's the sitch
what can i say except you're welcome and you said i would do it if you don't talk about bruno
that's so oh i cannot do poor unfortunate souls i would love to but i can't i can't belt right now
see the future i can see that's so guys i said like i meant not disney channel songs i mean disney
song like disney movie songs
oh strongy just hit 10k oh my god you go everybody go go tweet at her say congrats
you ain't never had a friend like me
ooh reflection
who is the girl i see staring straight back at me
it's a bunny woman
i can be alerted over she's like hey let's go yippee yippee
i'm so proud of her she literally just like i just want all the girls i just want all the girls
to be doing better than me and i'm like too bad you're also going to be doing really well
it's on that mom it's on them
oh gaston
who knows maybe maybe maybe i'll be next
no one i don't think i can belt that
sings like that's the new one sings like that's the new one something i don't know i'm just making
you shut up beauty and the beast oh beauty and the beast from beauty and the beast
i'll put that down i like that like because that'd be sweet to end on beauty and the beast
rage against the machine that's not that's not a disney song
i just came from the first vtuber energy video now i'm in love with y'all oh welcome welcome
thanks for i'm hope i hope you enjoy your stay here hello my name is she be caught on about
my favorite uh girl failure dom we're just doing karaoke i was literally just doing a gorilla
and then i just started to karaoke because that's that's how i am i'll be honest with you i've never
ever watched in a stage that don't hurt me
no actually the last one's gonna be i want i want some classic ones
and then i'll put we don't talk about bruno as a newer one what about a high school musical song
i don't know about this leaded frozen song yeah maybe you have to do an anastasia
watch along oh my god a 30 day fake are you trying to make me cry again
thank you for the 10 gifted oh my god i can't breathe i'm gonna put kiss the girl
all right off to the races
don't mind break me with money no
monsters university what was the last disney movie i saw i forget
did me i love moulin moulin's great i didn't like the new moulin movie though like the live
action that was kind of mid yes it's all disney songs we're ending on a disney song
silly goose we're ending on the disney song disney song disney song that's really good this is
yeah we got so many gifts and today i don't even i um rendered rendered turning right i
watched turning right with my mom it was cute she liked it i was like this cute
i remind me when i was younger and i really liked boy bands
easy moulin a circle of life i could have done um
this sapshan disgrace evil his plane is the scar on his face this sapshan an outraged disgrace
he asked for trouble the moment he came i love viking too
we should have a viking too one okay let's say be a man is the winner so we'll do that
i love be a man this is what this is my be a man is actually my favorite um disney song
and anybody starts like with a sentence with let's i'm usually like let's get down to
or somebody says let's get down to business i'm literally just like let's get down to business
all right we're ending on this be a man don't worry i'm not doing another archived karaoke
for members this is planned before this this is you guys it was i was supposed to do an
archived karaoke for members next week when i come back for my trip so that's funny
um
doing stitches your favorite oh what is my i don't know what's my favorite all-time disney
movie though i have to think about that
i have to make sure sometimes they like karaoke is wrong shut up wicks
which
why my best friend's loves uh she loves
the long stitch
okay good
let's go
let's get down to business to defeat the huns did they send me daughters when i asked for suns
you're the saddest bunch i've ever met but you can bet before we're through
mr i'll make a man out of you
tranquil as a forest but i'm far within
in once you find your center you are sure to win you're a spineless pale pathetic lot
and you haven't got a clue somehow i'll make a man out of you
um
i'm never gonna catch my breath saying goodbye to those who knew me
boy was i fooling school for cutting jam this guy's got him scared to death hope you
can see right through me now i wish we knew that i knew how to swim be a man we must be
swift as the coursing river man with all the strength of a great typhoon with all the strength
of a raging fire mysterious as the dark side of the moon time is racing towards us taking a drink
till the huns arrive heed my every order and you might survive you're unsuited for
the rage of war so pack up go home you're through how could i make a man out of you
you
be a man we must be swift as the coursing river with all the force of a great typhoon
with all the strength of a raging fire mysterious as the dark side of the moon
my internet my internet
time is racing don't my voice is going all right um but yeah this is a great priest precursor
to uh the concert tomorrow for you may plus so if you'd like cute girls singing make sure uh you
go to my waiting room make sure you press notify me and i'm doing a watch along of the you may plus
girls and they have their concert and um i love singing for you guys and uh the link is in the
chats the the chat the free chat so i'm sure that i will probably be singing along with the girls
if i know the songs i don't know if they're original songs or anything i'm very i can't
wait to be pleasantly surprised um jackie chan singing the chinese version that's so cool okay
let me turn off the effects um wow that was today has been a day that i did not expect
you guys doing it in one stream um no we're doing separate streams but i think honestly i might ask
if we can all be in a call we'll be just in react all at the same time excuse me it would make sense
too because we're all just gonna be you know actually i don't know don't don't don't take
anything i say because i don't know it is a watch along i don't we're not watching along is like
because when they announced it they announced this individually so maybe we all doing it we
are doing it all together i don't know you know i should have looked at the prompt that strawney
sent me like a good little gen mate um but i had a lot of fun today uh i'm generally floored by
all the support that you guys have given me um let me get rid of my microphone let me
untuck this from my bosom
time is racing towards us um thank you for pointing up with my my singing um i really want to definitely
do covers for you for your stuff and guys for i can't even talk i'm tired um
wow today has been a week and i needed i needed a good week because compared to what happened last
week um you guys know i care for you dearly even though your trash trash you know also
deserves to be loved um i'm glad you liked it i thank you for spoiling us thank you for spoiling me
like i literally came on here to make fun of a script and it turned into this whole thing
and i feel like i'm glad because i know like if this is like this and then we have like an actual
um what's it called we have a
firm another karaoke stream um when i come back from my vacation i'm very excited
we only spoil you because you spoil us so much more i try to i try to spoil you
you know i want to we're we're on equal equal footing in this relationship we're both on the
same ground we're both um partners in this all so i just want to i just want to be able to
provide for you in entertainment and other stuff the way you guys provide for me what's next after
you may plus concert um the you may plus concert is a little bit later it's at 8 p.m eastern time
i believe so i probably will be going to sleep after the the concert um
what's my schedule um and then on monday we have the twilight members watch along which
i'm looking forward to and then tuesday i have a collab with mercy we're playing super bunny man
i can't wait to play super muddy man with mercy because it's going to be so funny we're going to
be crying and i love hearing mercy laugh so it's going to be fun and oh boomie are you sleeping
in the bed next to me what if a boy you're going to be so tired um and then uh the next day after
that i have um an asmr prepared for you guys and be putting on your makeup i'm your older sister
using you as a guinea pig for makeup looks so i think that would be cute um i'll be honest with
you i'm a little stressed about my flight and like leaving and stuff and i'm very anxious and you
guys have been kind of really helping me get that anxiety off because i'll be flying by myself
and have a phone by myself in a very long time seeing my grandparents i'm gone from the 18th
through the 23rd i'll miss you guys so so so dearly i'll try to do um some sort of
like twitter space while i'm there maybe when my grandparents are out at like church or something
i can do they're at church and i'm just like hey guys welcome to the twitter space um but yeah
flying can be scary it's not i'm not worried about like flying it's like it's like moving
through an airport that i haven't been to in a very very long time um it's like it's all the
unknown like i know on a plane like i'm just on a plane that's fine i'm fine i'm fine flying but
like traveling by myself is scary especially as a girl um but yeah you guys over skipping bible
study for bible study being a makeup guinea pig is basically much okay so nothing will be changed
for you then yeah you know touching the bible when i'm gone by the way you cannot speak to the lord
you must you can't have any verses that stream will be really cathartic for me i've never had
anyone teach me how to do makeup growing up yeah hope everybody enjoys it i don't think you'll
actually get like actual makeup tips from me it's really just the triggers but yeah
i hope florida whatever yeah for the it's gonna be super hot i'm gonna die
make us like i'll make you so pretty yes ma'am during the twitter space what do you mean
no no we're not bible studying during the twitter space if you want to i will legit pull out the
bible that i probably have laying around and i will start reading you scripture do you think i'm
joking just like just to kill kill your bible i'll bring out my bible i hope i get to look as pretty
as you look of course you will i only wear like a little bit of eyeliner and i wear false eyelashes
and mascara as you can see my eyelashes are very long and i have very wonderful eyeliner and then
sometimes i like underline my eye you can kind of see it right on the side yeah i'm very minimalist
for makeup i should be you know you can't kill my bible messed up work for some of us that's too
bad i'm just doing my job you just got to do yours i don't know what's the problem
yes i overpower my bible with your bible i mean my bible with but i i'm tired
so pretty naturally oh thank you
it's hard to focus on work during the twitter space good i hope that was my goal
i wanted you guys to give me all your attention
yeah do you want to read the cover yeah you can read the cover you can like touch the cover and
stuff but you can't like flip through the pages or anything but if i don't believe in jesus
lord does he know i'm kidding i like this to support she be no don't say that
i got super red when you read my mirror oh yeah i was i was trying to figure out like who's
maro's blonde i can usually guess but i was fun looking at your guys's maros i was so live reacting
to some little treats that you guys sent me in cat pictures i love the cat pictures
it can't go to the end of the book until i say so
i got also got super embarrassed and giggly what do you guys want to school girls
um i would rather you not say who you are in the maros that's a no no
it's supposed to be anonymous for a reason i'm intentionally being sarcastic well
okay it's your text you're rewriting in text nobody can sense your sarcasm in tone through text
my brother my brother in christ his name is literally Levi exodus i should have just
known you read the bible your name is literally a bible book and a name within it
so when do you start when i leave so it'll be the 18th
you on the gotcha yay for you
you make me a school girl i make you a school i'm gonna turn you into a school girl when
i'm done with you how about that five days yeah study as much as you can did i win i'm so sorry
you didn't i'm so sorry you didn't
oh yeah let's go woman time
thank you three percent viewers that are women you are appreciated
turn me into school girl i hope this isn't waking anything in me
just wait tell me in azura's audio come out you guys have no idea what's coming
i think that's the beginning of august
you're a bible study
i'm so scared now why are you scared don't be don't be scared why are you scared there's
nothing to be scared of my love whatever what you be scared for i'll take care of you there's
nothing that you need to worry about you'll be the best little school girl for me won't you
and i bet you well you're so well behaved for me you're so sweet
yes you chose the purpose of where it's off to me
yeah i gotta keep your eyes on your toes i gotta i gotta switch it up and you'll be like oh she's
such a really dumb and i'm just like sit down and listen to what i have to say okay sit bark
beg good dog
okay they're so beanie and so cute
rodeo i'm already sat down we'll sit you lay on the floor then mother burger
try harder i'm immune to your charms totally not falling apart internally
i can start moaning i don't know
can we get a bark aim out that'd be good bark bark really good just a b a and r and a k and
you guys just spill out bark and look at the thing
oh my god let me put on some music
let's get it jazzy shall we okay i'll be honest with you i'm very upset because obias just updated
and it's ugly what they did to the audio mixer it's literally making me revolted i hate how thick
the lines are and i can't change it back they're like really thick boxes for the audio levels now
it's gross mark yeah that works like the b a r k that's funny
let's stick emo you maybe again they won't take time to make guys but definitely send me your
suggestions i guess some of them seem to be in maros mostly the baguettes are kind of funny
hello hi there but yeah um if you came from if you're new and you came for from the video
that smoothie made um thank you for stopping by and checking me out and checking the other
girls out i really appreciate it if you don't know who i am i am your favorite girl failure
dom sheebie cotton bum and i am a bunny dominatrix of healers gen one in dolj and um i also do
18 plus audio and patreon but most of the time i'm just a goofy dork on stream and then you get
the good stuff shibang yet oh no um and uh yeah i hope i hope you'll stick around a while check
me out fill me out a little bit we'll have fun i also like to voice act a lot i usually don't
like to sing so that's you guys you guys got me to sing yes i really do like you or something
um welcome welcome to the emo level sheebie sheebie get
ho ho ho you got you forgot to add ho ho ho at the end um but yeah i really love voice acting um
yeah and check out the other girls the other girls are lovely we love collabing together we love
spending time together um we all like fill a particular niche but uh we're not like pigeon
holding a niche so we all kind of like float around do things we like um playing games we like
we have a wonderful um team of people that also support us and we have a wonderful fan base so
i hope that you'll stay a while and i hope that you'll enjoy yourself
i didn't know you had debuted yet just saw the video came over easy subscribe oh
welcome yeah it seems like some people forgot that we debuted in June that's fine
they fill a niche but they're also amazing even when not playing into the roles exactly
exactly and then sometimes we play into each other's roles it's fun sometimes we just improv
like me and just say out totally crazy stuff oh my reina i have three cats and they like to
knock stuff over reina you're pulling out my headphones has already been three hours apparently
so um i also usually do endurance streams so like you might see the nice dream for like nine hours
of an elden ring because i love elden ring um and i also played elden ring for four hours and
formed and just improv the entire time he's telling you to stop before midnight it's 11 11
everybody make a wish my wish is that i hit 10k soon oh reina's purring and she's crawling into
my arms two hours of elden ring and seven hours of yapping oh yeah i also live hades i wanna play
hades when they come back it's 5 a.m here oh my god go to bed i wish for cats to be immortal me too
you also have elden ring no way
and sometimes i burp so i hope you don't mind i am now lady
the compilation of all your girls debuses hilarious i saw you shared it on twitter yeah
it's really awesome it's really funny we have we had so much fun with our debus we're all so nervous
we're like oh what if people don't like us but it's like i'm so thankful for the um
the type of reception that we've gotten it's really nice it's hotter with the purr sorry i
said my desk reina what's up mama come on she's like purring so hard on my shoulder
all right have a good night we get to hear burps and she's feeling i know sometimes
i used to give them out willy nilly but now i'm like you know what i'm too nice let me withhold
my burps because you know i'm running an establishment as madame of wonderland a
hotel that also doubles as a brothel don't tell anybody and i'm the madame of that establishment
uh it's only fair that a woman of my caliber upholds her professionalism while streaming to the masses
you know my favorite moment of view was when you had three heads on top of one in your chest
yeah be not afraid
so now we're kidding her reina makes you think of a gender swapped reign from the owl house
i never watched owl house as a kid
boomy king of umashu and he was another one of my cats he was in my desk with his paws crossed
like a gentleman i don't know where fia the deathbed companion who's my other cat her name is actually
fia the deathbed companion by the way because i love elden ring that much i think she's sleeping
under my bed boomy why are you just like laying his head in my hand
you're mad though because i touched his shoulder he only likes his head pat and now he's grooming
himself named us another cat d that would be so funny
what's a game that all the six dealer girls want to collab together one day well we wanted to do
power wash simulator but it didn't work out it like the for someone reason it just wasn't working
it like it would crash when there was four of us in there and you can have up to six people it was
really weird so i would like to play power wash simulator and i oh my god in the worst way i want
to play prop hunt and gary's mod i i have like over just like i have over 600 hours in counter
strike and i have over 600 hours in gary's mod because all i would do was play trouble in terraced
town in prop hunt and it was so great also uno yes i want to play uno i love if we had to play
like prop hunt with the you may plus girls or like with my thos it would be so funny so funny
so i'm trying to convince the girls to buy um very small it's only like five bucks or
i think might have been on five bucks for the steam sale but i think that's over so might be nine again
for ten
and i'm a i'm a prop hunt veteran so gonna go yes go to sleep go to sleep thank you so much
for your support and thank you for the song suggestions thank you gt you three different
youtuber agencies would be cool crazy it really would though it really would
you don't need counter strike source for some apps yeah that's true i forgot sometimes you
did desource for some of the maps nowadays i think you can just like download most of them out
mod packs oh my god i probably just do like the minecraft map one of my faves or office
i clocked seven forty five hours just messing with friends playing so they capture the classic
games you see plus mine so that strani would probably like thrive in that game she would i
think she would like it a lot i just i would love hearing her scream when she get discovered she'd
be like all right three flings i don't think they all fucking shit now they spotted me and then
she just fucking runs off i think it'd be so so funny
counter strike source is defensive or some random stuff but it happened or not that's
true honestly i'll buy it for everyone i literally i just don't give a shit be like here we go the
masses want gary's mod the masses will get gary's mod i can already hear mercy screaming whether
she's the hunter being hunted guys and then when she's chasing one of us to be like i can't do her
wait let me think of her laugh can't do her laugh that well
and then she'd laugh and like shoot us explode us
okay hey do do your part tell the other girls hey you guys should play this game because get
those suggestions out there if you watch the other girls and i hope you do give them their suggestions
tell them what's up i guess strani do impressions she does too many of them well
strani does really funny american accents i think i remember she was like trying to be southern
ones and i'm like what is this strani's rage heals my soul as well some scottish rage is a
different type of rage yes cool
you know we all get really goofy i think we really just like become our truest selves
in a collab especially the among us collab i can't get over how fun that was the among us
collab i want to do that again so bad i'm thinking of having some of my um friends on for the next
one like uh nori and chai chan it can be really fun
and then yeah emi and ic didn't get to do it last night last time
so i have a whole cute and funny and then there's me
i bet i could get like hexa and stuff
can't be funny some of the other hickenwashi girls
watch the clip of the among us collab in a sense of freaking funny yeah it was so funny
and it was well edited there was one i think that uh discount ostrich made he did like a really
meanie one that was really good shout out to discount ostrich he makes really good compilations
of us um and he did one of the among us collab and it was literally just so funny and then like
distrawni just like tricking all of us and like i knew i was on distrawni so many times when i
doubted myself because i'm like no she would never do that and then i was like why didn't i
listen to my gut i knew these people were the freaking uh imposters i would also like to do
like town of salem um i love you still love playing town of salem
and i feel like that would be kind of better because then we wouldn't have to move around
as much we could just like talk and just debate the entire time i think that'd be funny
i'm drunk hello mom are you behaving young man you can only drink at the house you know make sure
you're safe town of salem super dead oh no i know i haven't played that in a long time i've seen
like there's like among us adaptations of it so i think maybe that the company was absorbed or whatever
and then they started with just angrily shouting i remember someone accused her but switched it up
when you all caught on literally she was like i'll be quiet almost like something's up
all right i'm getting eepy i have a lot to do tomorrow i have to go
guys what are you i need to tell you something funny my um
yeah oh hi fia oh hi where have you been she's like very excitedly trying to jump over my lap
hi come here little girl i know why are you trying to grab me she's like reaching out with
her paws trying to reach me make it go up oh big stretch as i pick you up she just goes limps
hi fia oh my little rummy girl she's no fart on me you're shimpy um
my dad is having like a bourbon tasting at my parents house and i have to go over and get the um
get the get the suitcase from my parents house because i don't have one and i'm gonna borrow
one of my moms and my dad's like can you come at this time and i'm like why do why he's like
because i want to show you my my beautiful daughter off to all my friends and i'm like dad please
don't try to set me up with anybody i swear to god i'm coming an hour early i swear to god
i'm not dealing with this i have too much to do oh my god
that's it's my dad just being like please get married already please can't you find yourself
a man please please like my my dad's like where's my where's the grandchildren
oh my dad loves kids and my mom's like you're fine you don't have to have any kids and i'm like
thanks mom my dad's like don't tell her that kids are great look how she turned out and i'm like
i'm mentally ill and my dad's like all right you know already married and i'll tell him that
because i know like if i go over there they're gonna be like oh what do you do for work i'm gonna be
like i'm a whore on the internet would you like do you want that no you don't i'm mentally ill
and i role play a dominatrix bunny woman on the internet does that turn you on actually well
it turns you guys on this is different no this is i know you guys it gets you guys going that's
different they're normies though they're don't normies they don't know anything about youtubers
oh my god you're the perfect woman okay at least you have someone on your side with this
bro even my sister thinks or expects me to be a parent but not with our cursed lineage i know
i like the worst health issues i do not want to pass that down to a child
hams crowd the area like prosels like suitors and virgin i love virgin virgin is one of my
favorite shows of the whole time i would love a virgin styled outfit
we're all here for a reason are you guys all here to fight for my hand
oh my goodness are you here to fight for my hands you can't tell but i'm holding out my hands so you
can kiss my my hands someone like me oh no you couldn't
guys don't worry i'm not i'm literally going there for five seconds and i'm grabbing a suitcase and
i'm running away i'm like nervous to mention anything because i don't want people to feel like
oh no she's leaving us for people no relax sweetheart please sweetie i love you please
i'm not leaving you get it through your head i'm shaking you i'm choking you and i'm shaking at
the fucking time punch the mic punch the mic punch the mic i know but there's always two of you
that are like i'm feeling cocked and i don't want you to feel that way so i'm just prefacing it
okay relax
you can collectively marry madame and then commit oh would you like a
ooh the son of an asmr she be on your wedding night
getting married to she be i've never like really thought of weddings to be honest with you like
i've never like planned anything like i have friends that like i've been dreaming on this
wedding since i was five years old and i'm like i just never been that type of person
and then again because i grew up so religious i'm like i'm just awkward anyways let me just
let me not like just like totally i'm just gonna shit on myself and expose myself a bit more how
weird i am um nori already said they were gonna do what did she say that she said she was gonna
draw me as ice spice is what she told me she's drawing me in a wedding dress where are you nori
i'm hunting you down she wants wolves so we under what
why are just the new hot those weird things don't make you better though oh yes my religious
trauma so good so hot so sexy oh there you go
early in the stream when the gifted members were happening those were everybody just proposing to
me oh that's when she said that she was drawing that oh okay i have to message her then and say thank
you nori called you wife and then the chat was going so fast and then i wasn't looking at okay i
need to message her right now and say i'm sorry hi i love you
she's streaming right now i wish i could redirect to someone streaming on twitch
also my friend isn't at oh
so
also i love you and thank you
and you are my wife she's my girl wife
and prompt you typing asmr manual raid well she is streaming right now
oh let me post her i'm actually yeah let's do that let me pull up her twitch
and i'm gonna make you guys all go to this link right now she's gonna be freaking out she'd be like
what
i gotta remember what her thing is because she
doesn't have that as the same thing where girl where are your freaking links at
watch there you go marimocos
all right manual raid you guys are all going so if you don't know who nori is nori has been a
longtime friend of mine when i first started as a vtuber she is the one person um who gave me a chance
and she used to be very big but she rebranded because she wanted to be small again
and she was the only person that ever gave me a chance i literally had zero viewers she was a
bigger streamer than i was and i love her to death she's the cutest girl um she's cute and funny
she's very based she's hilarious the raid message just be like surprise bunny raid that's fine
um but yeah give her my love i'm gonna go to bed i should probably eat something too
yes don't worry i did eat today i had a nice grain bowl with some quinoa some canoa
some quinoa and some veggies and avocado i ate very healthy today everybody yeah surprise bunny
so tell her surprise bunny raid go now go go go i'm gonna pin it you guys are talking too fast i
can't pin it nope i didn't mean to pin your message hold on let me remove this
sorry i didn't mean to delete your message i just meant to unpin it
chat's moving so fast i can't do anything
i
can't talk i don't have a twitch
they don't they haven't given me access to my twitch yet i literally was watching
fallen shadows redebut you i couldn't even say anything
okay i give her love she deserves it
what is she doing she's doing 100 what is she playing she's playing king of hearts
i can't say anything tell her tell her i say hi somebody say she be says hi and she loves you
okay bye everybody bye cross platform raid cross platform raid i'm just gonna end stream
i'm not gonna bother with a ending thing bye love you kisses you guys are so good to me today
i don't know what i do without you thank you i am so i'm so not deserving of this but i
appreciate you guys so much have a good night sleep well have a good day